Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was hast du zuletzt verloren?
Ein Kopfkissen in einem Hotelzimmer, denn ich reise ja immer mit Kissen. Ja, damit hättest du nicht gerechnet.
Das klingt dramatisch. Also ich weiß, du hast große Koffer oder viele Koffer, weil da Kopppkissen drinstecken.
Eines. Okay. Und zwar habe ich einen besonderen Bezug. Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe ein besonderes Kissen mit so einem Schaumstoff. Auf das kann man sich nur seitlich legen und das ist sehr gut für den Rücken und ist gut für einen erholsamen Schlaf. Und wenn man sich einmal an dieses Kissen gewöhnt hat, dann kann man nicht mehr ohne ein solches Kissen schlafen. Ist also sehr verzweifelt, wenn man es mal vergessen hat. Dadurch, dass man aber ein Kissen im Bett liegen hat und dann packt man den Koffer und dann ja bleibt das schon mal im Hotelzimmer liegen. Also habe ich jetzt in meinem Koffer einen großen Zettel angebracht. Da steht Kissen drauf. Das heißt, wenn ich den Koffer packe, den Anzug reinlege, etc., dann denke ich im letzten Moment noch, ah ja, da war doch was, das Kissen.
Ich will jetzt folgendes Bild zeichnen. Eigentlich reißt man mit so Sachen, keine Ahnung, mal so Klamotten, dann hat man Rucksack, in denen kann man das so reinschnüren, platzsparend. Und das Kissen, wie du es beschreibst, scheint für mich so nicht im Volumen reduzierbar. Es lässt sich nicht falten, wie auch immer.
Nein.
Also die Idee, dass man übersehen könnte, ob man das Größte, was man überhaupt dabei hat, das muss ja bei dir verschwinden oder übergroße Ausmaße, sodass das Kissen darin verschwinden kann, an dem wenn du reist.
Ja, ja, aber ich bin dann manchmal so, dann liegt das im Bett und da weiße Laken, weißes Kissen und dann geht man raus und achtet darauf, dass man vielleicht sein Handy mit dabei hat und das Bottmanninn nicht vergisst und denkt dann gerade nicht ans Kissen. Und dann habe ich natürlich zu Hause noch ein Ersatzkissen liegen, damit ich niemals ohne das Kissen schlafen muss. Es wurde mir auch schon mal aus Hotel zurückgeschickt. Zum Teil sind sie dann aber auch ganz verlustig gegangen. Aber jetzt mit diesem Zettel, den ich jetzt angebracht habe, ich dachte, es kann nicht sein, dass ich laufend auf Reisen einen Kissen liegen lasse, geht es.
Sehr gut. Ich will kurz eine Verlustgeschichte aus diesem Monat schildern. Ich fahre Fahrrad und plötzlich sagt mir mein Handy, du hast dein Portemonnaie vergessen. Und ich denke, nee, komisch. Dann gucke ich nach, wo es ist. Es hat ja ein AirTag. Es liegt auf der Straße. Also fahre ich zurück und in dem Moment war es aber schon weg. Meine Kopfhörer lagen noch da. Das Kissen, sag ich schon, mein Portemonnaie war weg. Es stellte sich dann am nächsten Morgen heraus, jemand hat es gefunden und mitgenommen. Was für mich die Frage aufwirft, wie gehe ich um mit Sachen, die ein AirTag haben, die ich finde? Typischerweise findet man irgendwo ein Handschuh und denkt sich, ich lege den an die sichtbarste Stelle, derjenige kommt zurück und holt ihn. Das ist natürlich bei einem AirTag ganz anders. Mein Tipp jetzt ist, nehmt es nicht mit nach Hause, denn als ich angeschrieben wurde, ich habe offenbar von dir, ich habe gegoogelt, vielleicht bist du das ja, der Stefan Schulz, ich habe ein Portemonnaie gefunden, habe ich gesagt, ja, ich sehe es in dieser und dieser Straße mit Hausnummer C. Und er so, ups, ich kann es morgen abholen. So, wenn man Erdtex-Sachen findet, damit sie der Eigentümer wiederfindet und nur er versteckt sie, legt es ins Gebüsch unter ein Auto, so an die Bordsteinkante, dass es niemand sonst sieht. Und derjenige, der das entsprechende Telefon dazu hat, wird das schon finden. Und niemand sonst. Also Sachen liegen lassen und ein bisschen verstecken, sodass derjenige da kommt, weil wenn es erstmal woanders ist, denkt man, nee, oder muss ich jetzt alle meine Karten sperren? Ich habe also meine Kreditkarte sperren lassen. Nun ist aber so, ich für ein modernes Leben, das heißt, ich kriege keine Post nach Hause, sondern die Post geht zum Postscanner. Der Post als Angebot für 15 Euro im Monat wird meine Post gescannt. Aber nur scannbare Post. Eine Kreditkarte, die mir zugeschickt wird, weil die alte gesperrt und neue kriege ich, kann dort nicht verarbeitet werden. Sie liegt also entweder noch dort als wird nicht gescannt, wird am Ende des Monats hingeschickt oder wie auch immer. Ich habe also gerade keine Kreditkarte und dann fiel mir aber erst währenddessen auf, ich habe da gar nicht dran gedacht, ich habe ja nicht im Supermarkt war, einfach weiter mit meinem Handy bezahlt, stellt sich raus. Apple Pay ist so konzipiert, dass wenn ich sage, meine Karte ist weg, bitte sperrt sie, sagt meine Bank automatisch, alles klar, wir schicken dir eine neue. Und dann wird mein Handy angepingt und dann wird die einfach in meiner Wallet ersetzt. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt schon eine funktionstüchtige neue Kreditkarte, ohne dass ich etwas tun musste, in meinem Handy. Aber ich kann nirgendwo Kreditkarten, Karten, Daten anbieten, weil ich weiß die Nummer nicht vollständig. Sie wird mir nirgendwo angezeigt. Und ich habe auch diese drei Zahlen, die man noch zur Sicherheit braucht, auch nicht. Und das ist doch irre, dass diese Digitalisierung, die auf der einen Seite ist komplett, du merkst es gar nicht. Deine Karte wurde erneuert und du bist komplett aufgeschmissen, weil das Plastikteil, das in der Post zu dir geschickt wird, ist halt irgendwo. Ja, also diese, das absolute Verstecken von Verlust.
Du erlebst einen doppelten Verlust. Du erlebst einmal den Verlust deines Portmonees. Das findet sich dann wieder. Aber du erlebst jetzt eigentlich den Verlust deiner Autonomie.
Das auch. Aber ich habe sie ja noch, solange ich mit meinem Handy bezahle. Ja, das heißt, dieser Verlust wurde komplett, ist komplett verschwunden. Da wurde einfach von mir verborgen. Ich habe das gar nicht mitbekommen. Das ist einfach aktualisiert worden.
Beziehungsweise der Verlust. Und damit kommen wir zu einem Begriff, der erst sehr später in diesem Buch kommt. Dieser Verlust wurde dann repariert. Also die Reparatur der Moderne. Also in diesem Buch kommt es irgendwann mal darauf hinaus, dass man die Moderne auch reparieren kann.
Dieses Buch hat 425 Seiten. Und das, wovon du gerade sprichst, ist Seite 418.
Ja, das heißt, wir beide schätzen einen gewissen Fortschritt. Ich bei der Kissenproduktion. Deshalb möchte ich nicht auf so einem normalen Kissen liegen. Du hast den Fortschritt im Portemonnaie mit dir. Du hast die Kreditkarten, hast aber eigentlich das iPhone, das dann das meiste an Verlust kompensieren kann und am praktischsten ist. Und das heißt aber, dass wir also mit zu gewinnen, umgehen und mit Verlusten gleichermaßen. Und wir schauen dann, was kompensiert was. Und bei mir ist es dann auch noch das händisch geschriebene Zettelchen, das mich auf das Kissen hinweist, das repariert, dass ich laufend irgendwas vergesse. Wir sind jetzt hier im sehr allgemeinen und manche werden sich ein bisschen fragen, was tun wir? Ja, wir messen hier eigentlich die Gegenwart. Und würden uns, ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier für beide spreche, aber ich würde mir wünschen, das Buch würde das viel stärker tun. Und hätte es vielleicht bei solchen konkreten Punkten viel deutlicher gemacht, wie es anfangs auch aussieht. Weil es geht anfangs um konkrete Verluste, um auch eine Politik der Verluste, wenn es wieder heißt, Make America Great Again. Darauf wird Bezug genommen oder auf untergehende Inseln. Oder es geht um Pflanzen, nämlich die Benin-Pflanzen, die zurückgegeben werden müssen. Also es geht etwas verloren, aber es wird woanders etwas hingebracht. Andreas Reckwitz ist ein sehr prominenter Soziologe. Vor allem durch seine Gesellschaft der Singularitäten hat er einen Bestseller geschrieben, der weithin zitiert wird. Und jetzt legt er ein Buch vor, bei dem er sich den Begriff Verlust nähert, beziehungsweise den Verlust als ein Grundproblem der Moderne ausmacht. Und was tut er eigentlich? Er definiert verschiedene Formen von Verlusten. Und ich würde fast so weit gehen, das Buch wäre vielleicht als Nachschlagewerk geglückt, wenn man gesagt hat, dies ist das Verlustlexikon. Es gibt 700 Begriffe, verschiedene zum Verlust. Es gibt zum Beispiel Verlusteskalation. Es gibt Verlustschübe. Es gibt dann ein Trotz, der auf Verluste reagiert, eine Resignation, die auf Verluste reagiert. Das hätte man also lexikalisch aufarbeiten können. Er hat sich entschieden, das in einen Fleece-Text zu gießen. Und ich bin von diesem Buch nicht angetan. Ich glaube, wir können jetzt ein produktives Gespräch darüber führen. Aber ich bin nicht glücklich damit, was ich hier lese, denn dies ist ein Buch, das wunderschöne Wortschöpfungen uns anbieten kann. Nur komme ich damit der Realität, in der ich lebe, in der wir leben, komme ich damit den Verlusten, die wir erfahren, wirklich näher, wenn ich sage, na, das ist ein Verlustschub. Und das ist eine Reaktion, das ist der Trotz. Und das ist aber Verlustscham. Und das ist Verlustangst. Ich kann natürlich versuchen, mit so einer Präzisierung der Begriffe, die mir über die Sachlageklarheit zu verschaffen, nur führt das bei Reckwitz, und ich werde nachher Beispiele bringen, dazu, dass wir irgendwann nur noch schöne Worte präsentiert bekommen und die gesellschaftliche Analyse eigentlich ausbleibt. Wir haben hier einige Soziologen gesprochen. Die meisten kamen bei dir nicht besonders gut weg. Aber das frage ich dich am Anfang. Würdest du doch zugestehen, dass jemand wie Blüthorn oder auch jetzt aus der Politikwissenschaft Veit Selk ja doch etwas machen, nämlich sie gehen einem Gedanken nach und versuchen, zumindest, jetzt sagst du, das ist nicht geglückter Soziologen, sie versuchen tatsächlich eine Theorie zu entwickeln. Vor allem Blüthorn versucht, eine Theorie zu entwickeln. Hier habe ich ganz klar den Eindruck, dass wir es mit einem ja Medley zu tun haben, aus allem, was derzeit und was große Soziologen einstmals über Verluste geschrieben haben. Und das erlebe ich hier in einer großen Kompilation. Gut geschrieben, aber wohin führt es denn?
Ja, sehr gute Frage. Ich will es wie folgt, da du es jetzt einbettest in unsere bisherigen Salon-Lektüren, möchte ich da auch kurz rekapitulieren. Wir haben Veit Selke lesen, Demokratiedämmerung mit dem Argument, die Demokratie scheitert und damit ist auch die Demokratie-Theorie gescheitert. Und ich habe in unserem Gespräch gesagt, die Demokratie-Theorie hatte immer nur praktischen Nutzen für Sonntagsreden, Plädoyers und Wahlkämpfe als soziologischer Herangehensweise, aber diese Einladung taugte sie nie. Also die Demokratie-Theorie war immer nur eine semantische Demokratie-Verherrlichung. Sie entsprach nie ihrem Gegenstand. Und die Demokratie wurde beschädigt durch diese Verherrlichung. Das erleben wir ja auch jetzt, wo ich sage, wenn der Finanzminister geht, die Regierung keine Mehrheit mehr hat, kommt es besonders darauf an, dass die Demokratie funktioniert. Und das tut sie, denn es wird bis auf einen Sitz genau ausgezählt, wie die Mehrheiten sind. Und das war es. Nur wenn man die ganze Zeit verherrlicht mit, nein, sie müssen sich auch gut verstehen, wie eine Familienbande die Regierung organisieren. Und im besten Fall stehen die Journalisten daneben und sind beruhigt davon, dass sich Mama und Papa gut verstehen und sich auch um die Nachbarn kümmern. Dann scheitert es. So, also in dem Höhepunkt des demokratischen Auslebens, das wir jetzt gerade erleben, wird plötzlich behauptet, es sei alles am Ende. Und ich habe dem widersprochen. Ich habe gesagt, nein, es ist nicht am Ende. Es ist einfach nur die Demokratie, wie sie eigentlich gedacht war und nicht, wie sie bisher verherrlicht wurde.
Aber man konnte eine stringente Argumentation ja bei Seg nachvollziehen.
Ja, von mir aus. Aber sie hatte keine Korrelation zur Realität.
Die vermisse ich aber hier, diese große argumentative Herreinigung.
Bei Blüthorn hatten wir ein Buch, von dem der Autor selbst sagte, ich habe schon drei Mal in dem Buch versucht, meinen Punkt deutlich zu machen. Das ist mein vierter Entwurf. Es gibt ein sozio-emanzipatorisches Projekt oder ein öko-emanzipatorisches. Also wir wollen gleichzeitig die Welt retten, was nur durch Beschränkung unseres Lebens geht. Und gleichzeitig verherrlichen wir das individuelle Ausleben meiner Möglichkeiten. Also ich möchte den Christian Lindner Porsche, aber gleichzeitig die Welt retten, das passt nicht. Und da habe ich gesagt, ja gut, man kann das alles so reformulieren. Und umso strenger man das macht, umso mehr nährt man sich seiner eigenen Semantik an, die man im Buch entwirft und sagt, das passt nicht. Und dann sage ich, ja, das passt nicht, aber die Grundbegriffe sind falsch, die Konzepte sind falsch, der historische Aufriss ist falsch und die Beobachtung der Gegenwart ist auch falsch. Ich kann damit leider nichts anfangen, aber die intrinsische Logik ist gegeben. Also dieses Zugeständnis würde ich machen.
Darf ich einen Satz, aber es ist der einzige Satz, den ich zu blüdern sage heute. Ich verspreche es. Es gibt einen Song, bitte mal alle hören, von Gitte. Ich glaube 1982. Der heißt Ich will alles. Gitte steht für so einen emanzipatorischen Schlager. Der Song geht, ich will alles, ich will alles und zwar sofort, eh der letzte Keim in mir zu Staub verdorrt. Ich will leben, will mich geben, so wie ich bin. Und was mich kaputt macht, nehme ich nicht mehr hin. Und jetzt kommt es. Niemand speist mich ab. Niemand macht mich satt. Zulang habe ich verzichtet und mich selber klein gemacht. Das ist das emanzipatorische Projekt, Feminismus zweite Welle, 80er Jahre, Selbstverwirklichung nicht verzichten. Und es ist exakt das, was wir dann in diesem Clip, den du uns damals gespielt hast, wiederfinden, wenn Ecke Heidenreich sagt, wir haben die Frauenrechte nach vorne gebracht, aber wir sind auch nach Palermo und die Oper geflogen. Genau. Und das gehört aber auch beides irgendwie zusammen. Und ich glaube, das beschreibt Blütern sehr, sehr gut.
Genau. Das beschreibt er sehr gut, nur damit beschreibt er halt das. Und ich möchte aber die Welt beschreiben und nicht nur das.
Aber jetzt zu Reckwitz.
So, Reckwitz macht uns jetzt hier ein Angebot. Wir müssen jetzt kurz im Sinne von verorten. Denn Andreas Reckwitz schreibt nicht einfach nur ein Buch zum Thema Verlust, sondern er ist ein viel gelesener Autor. Die Leute haben ein spezifisches Interesse. Es gab Berichte in der Buchmesse, in denen Journalisten sich darüber freuten, ganz affirmativ die Beobachtung teilten. Die Leute stehen Schlange bei Steffen Mau, bei Andreas Reckwitz und so weiter und so fort. Die Soziologen sind anscheinend wieder im Kommen. So, nun lesen wir aber dieses Buch. Wir gehen nicht nach, was Reckwitz auf der Buchmesse gesagt hat. Wir gehen nicht nach, was er drei Stunden lang bei der Zeit im Politik-Teil-Podcast gesagt hat. Wir gehen nicht nach, was er im Zurkampf-Podcast noch mal 45 Minuten. Denn man macht dort überall dieselbe Beobachtung. Er versucht, etwas zu erklären. Aber er erklärt es nicht, sondern er deklariert. Er hat also eine Idee von, wie muss man heute beobachten? Ich würde sagen, die Einstiegsschneisen sind immer theoretisch, nicht grundbegrifflich. Man kann sich nicht einfach einen Grundbegriff raussuchen und dann sagen, das erklärt alles, sondern man braucht eine ganze Theorie. Es würde aber komplett scheitern, diesen deklarativen Ansatz, also die Leute von der Zeit, die Leute auf der Buchmesse und die Leute bei Sokamp, werfen ihm einfach so Stichpunkte hin und er sagt dann, ja, und das ist ja auch hier Verlust und da Verlust und es war schon immer Verlust und es wird Verlust sein, es ist mehr Verlust, weniger Verlust, was auch immer, Verlust, Verlust, Verlust. So, also diese Reformulierungen, er beschreibt das, aber nicht das, was uns analysiert, nämlich die ganze Welt. Das gelingt einfach in diesen Gesprächen. Es ist also keine erklärende, sondern grundbegriffdeklarierende Soziologie, die uns, diese Kritik teile ich, nicht weiterhilft, gar nicht weiterhilft. Wir können uns aber annähern zu dem, was uns der Autor eigentlich mit seinem Werk sagen wollte, indem wir wirklich sein Werk uns nehmen, also das Buch und nicht jetzt diesen deklarativen Erklärungen. Niemand streitet mit Andreas Reckwitz über die Grundbegriffe, über die Auswahl, über das, was aus diesen Grundbegriffen folgt. Das sind ja 500 Seiten Text. Und jetzt kommt der konstruktive Dreh, den ich machen möchte, denn ich habe so viele Notizen wie nie. Und es ist nun mal in der Soziologie so, Menschen dürfen, das ist gewünscht, gefordert und wird einem auch antrainiert, Vorschläge unterbreiten, beispielsweise neuen Grundbegriff. Und dann kann man das lesen und sagen, der Vorschlag ist gescheitert. Aber vielen Dank für den Input, denn als Inspiration taugt er allemal. Und jetzt haben wir hier es mit so einem Vorschlag zu tun, bei dem ich sage, ich wünsche mir, dass Soziologen ganz in der Gegenwart und ganz an einem Gemütszustand anknüpfen und eine Idee formulieren. Und sie darf dann aber auch scheitern. Also ich freue mich darüber, dass es das Buch gibt, aber ich erkläre es auch für gescheitert. Und das ist sozusagen der Dreh- und Angelpunkt-Ausgangslage für das, was wir jetzt besprechen.
Damit kann ich viel anfangen. Es ist ja so, dass erst einmal die Überlegung sehr naheliegend ist, zu sagen, wo der Fortschritt sich beschleunigt und intensiviert. Da gehen ja Dinge verloren. Wir können das dann etwas ganz Konkretem festmachen. Das iPhone 7 ist dann nicht mehr so wertvoll. Ja, es ist das Beste, das heißt aber davor, dass es nicht mehr das Beste ist. So weiß man dann also immer, das Bessere ist der Feind des Guten. So zieht sich das durch die Moderne hindurch. Das heißt, die Moderne mit diesem Fortschritt, dass das Nächste jetzt kommt, das noch Bessere, das wiederum führt dazu, dass alles, was davor passiert ist, eine Entwertung erfährt und auch als Verlust empfunden. Jetzt wird niemand sagen, Mensch, das war aber schön, als man das iPhone 6 hatte. Schade, dass wir das nicht behalten konnten. Warum gab es jetzt das Update? Bei anderen Dingen wird das aber schon so gesehen. Stichwort Verbrenner. Warum können wir nicht ewig den Verbrenner fahren? Oder wir haben ganz andere Sachen. Dann zum Beispiel, wenn es um nationale Identität geht, warum ist das nicht mehr so wie früher? Warum ist nicht mehr so wie in der Bonner Republik? Also diese Erfahrungen sind alle da. Ihr sagt, Reckwitz, selbstredend gab es immer Verluste, die Menschen erfahren haben. Aber diese Moderne beschleunigt eigentlich die Verluste. Und zugleich hat die Moderne ein großes Problem damit, mit Verlusten umzugehen, weil sie ja immer nur Verbesserungen verspricht. Und da muss ja eigentlich diese Negativität, die im Verlust liegt, ausgeklammert werden. Und der erste Mal ist diese Grundüberlegung gut. Und ich würde so weitgehend zu sagen, das als 100-seitigen Essay hätte ich sehr gern gelesen und glaube ich, hätte uns sehr viel weitergebracht. Was nämlich dann passiert in diesem Buch ist, dass er versucht, uns die Begrifflichkeit immer weiter auseinander zu dividieren, was eigentlich für verschiedene Verluste vorzufinden sind und was er dann auch noch macht ist, dass er immer wieder es schafft und das ist eine gewisse Marotte der Soziologie, das weiß ich wohl, dass die Binse, sage ich mal, in eine soziologische, intellektualistische Sprechweise zu packen, dass ich denke, ja, aber am Ende ist es doch der Satz, das bessere ist der Feind des Guten oder so etwas. Also ich will mal ein Beispiel für eine solche Binse geben. Und zwar sagt er dann, der Zyklus der Jugendlichkeit ist allerdings unerbittlich. Mit dem eigenen Altern in der Zukunft wird die Jugend der Gegenwart das gleiche Schicksal ereilen. Die Gewinner von heute sind auch hier die Verlierer von morgen. Man sagt ja, stimmt irgendwie, muss man es noch mal aufschreiben, weiß ich nicht. Generell gilt, dort, wo die allgemeine Empfindungsfähigkeit steigt, werden auch Verluste stärker empfunden. Ja, also wer stärker empfindet, empfindet auch stärker Verlust. Oder ich frage mich auch, was sind das für Erklärungen? Also ich greife das jetzt mal so ein bisschen wahllos aus. Wir versuchen nachher eine Struktur da reinzubringen. Da geht es also um den Verlust von Menschen. Eine erste Gruppe von Verlust-Phenomenen bildet die konkreten Verluste, also die körperlichen, menschlichen und die materiellen Dinglichen. Regelmäßig sind sie mit starken emotionalen Reaktionen verbunden. Als Prototyp dieses Verlusts erscheint der Tod von Menschen, also das Ableben von Angehörigen, wird dann nochmal erklärt, von nicht verwandten Mitgliedern der eigenen sozialen Gruppe oder auch von Fremden, sofern deren Tod das Subjekt in irgendeiner Weise betrifft. Es kann sich um den Tod eines einzelnen geliebten Menschen handeln oder um den eines ganzen Kollektivs, etwa bei einem Unfall oder einem Genozid. Auch der eigene Tod in der nahen oder fernen Zukunft kann vom Individuum als ein schmerzhafter Verlust antizipiert werden. Dann denke ich mir, warum schreibt man das auf? Also ja, Verlust kann erfahren werden, wenn Freunde sterben, wenn Familiemitglieder sterben, wenn Leute, die einem sonst nahe stehen, ausgelöscht werden oder verunfallen. Und der eigene Tod kann einem auch Angst machen, dass man das mal alles verliert.
Hättest du ja nicht gewusst, ne?
Wäre nicht gut, dass ich das noch mal nachlese. Und das geht über so viele Seiten in dieser Art. Das ist ja jetzt nur mal gerade rausgegriffen, aber ich könnte jetzt 50 Seiten dieser Art zitieren. Und ich frage mich, warum macht man das? Will man einfach nur sagen, ich beherrsche die Sprache so gut, dass ich auch die einfachsten Dinge des Lebens, die jeder weiß, noch mal so auf eine soziologische Formel bringen kann, dass es gelehrt klingt?
Genau. Warum macht man das ist genau die richtige Frage. Liegt da die Performance eines Autors, der sich einfach mit einem Begriff, von dem er im Grunde weiß, das Buch werden 1,7 Millionen Leute wahrnehmen, aber nur 80.000 lesen. Er kann also den Verlust als Grundbegriff legen und sich dann daraufhin ins Gespräch bringen zum Thema Verlust.
Das war ja deine Anfangsthese schon, als wir das ankündigten, dass wir darüber reden, und das hat sich sehr bestätigt.
So, und jetzt gehen wir aber in diesen Text und wollen ihm den Verlust als Grundbegriff wieder aus der Hand schlagen. Wir müssen aber zuerst sagen, der Einstieg ist sehr gut. Denn wir haben ja auch die Frage gestellt, Verlust und er hatte ja diesen Einklip haben wir ja gespielt, aus diesem Drei-Stunden-Gespräch mit der Zeit. Er hat kurz die Täter genannt. Es gibt also nicht nur Verlust und Verlierer, sondern der Verlierer hat, wenn es um ein Nullsums-Spiel geht, auch Gewinner. Das heißt zum Beispiel eine Inflation sagt immer, etwas ist teuer zu kaufen. Aber es gibt ja auch einen Verkäufer. Es gibt einen Vermieter. Es sind ja nicht alles nur Mieter und Käufer und Publikum der Politik, sondern manche sind ja auch woanders positioniert. Und ich hatte ja eine gewisse Vorfreude, dass das hier Thema wird. Ja, also dass Verlust verrechnet wird.
Irgendwann kommt noch einmal Täter, ich glaube, so um die Seite 400 rum.
Wir gehen es mal chronologisch durch. Das heißt, irgendwann begegnen sie uns. Aber bis dahin können wir schon nichts mehr damit anfangen. Also der Einstieg ist so, die Klimakrise, du hast genannt, die Namen der Insel, die untergehen. Und er schreibt, es ist doch bemerkenswert, wie sich die negativen gesellschaftlichen Zukunftserwartungen verfestigen. Und gleich am Anfang schreibt er, während weltweit eine sehr kleine Gruppe von Reichen und Superreichen stark profitiert. Da würde ich sagen, wenn diese Unterscheidung auf Seite 3 von 500 aufgemacht wird, habe ich Vorfreude. Ja, weil dann scheint es offenbar nicht nur gegenwärtig und an einem Gemütszustand, sondern auch wichtig zu sein, was hier verhandelt wird. Er kommt auf Europa, Nordamerika zu sprechen, wo das Wohlstandsniveau nun stagniert und eine Mittelklasse aber zurückfällt. Da würde ich sagen, gerade mit der Nennung von Branko Milanovic, ist es ja besonders triftig, jetzt zu sagen, oh, das ist genau der richtige Einschlag. Denn wenn wir feststellen, dass Superreiche profitieren, aber selbst in den reichen Regionen Europas, Nordamerikas der Wohlstand stagniert und die Mittelklasse zurückfällt, dann erstellen sich hier doch wirklich Verrechnungsprobleme. Dann kann man den Verlust mal kurz vorstellen als Einstieg, aber dann wird sofort eiskalt durchgerechnet. Was ich jetzt auch empfehle für angehende Soziologen, dass sie sich in der Gegenwart bedienen, um Interessanz und Anlässe zu finden und dann aber all in gehen und sofort den Leser sozusagen an der Nase durch die Manege führen, um zu sagen, hier, schau dir diese Sachen mal genau an. Und das wäre hier zum Beispiel möglich gewesen. Keine Zahl. Genau, wenn er Zahlen, Strukturen, Geschichten mal zusammengebaut hätte. Grundsätzlich fehlt hier ein narrativer Ansatz. Also man kann wahllos in dieses Buch hereingreifen und man könnte jetzt nicht vororten, wo ist er gerade, sondern das ist so sprunghaft und so weiter.
Aber gut, wir sind noch am Anfang, wo er noch von den Modernisierungsverlierern Aber es suggeriert, das muss man sagen, das ist jetzt nicht wie bei den Franzosen, die assoziativ loslegen und irgendwo rauskommen. Das ist nicht wie Virio lesen oder sowas, sondern er suggeriert eigentlich eine wahnsinnige Struktur. Jetzt kommen sechs Punkte dazu, dann fünf Punkte dazu. In Wahrheit aber zerfliest das alles schon während des Lesens. Und man weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, warum baut jetzt das eine auf das andere auf? Und warum müssen jetzt da Verlustschübe hinkommen und dort Verlusteskalationen?
Nur am Anfang, sagt er uns kurz. Es gibt Modernisierungsverlierer, wir haben eine neue soziale Ungleichheit, wir haben das Ende der klassischen Industriegesellschaft, wir haben Effekte, also Spuren, die hinterlassen werden im sozialräumlichen, demografischen und selbst gesundheitlichen Bereich. Alles Themen, auf die man hier lange eingehen könnte. Wir haben eine niedrige Geburtenrate plus Abwanderung, wir haben eine dramatische Entleerung ländlicher Regionen und die Lebenserwartung sinkt auch noch. Wir sind also irgendwo auf Seite 17 und sagen, wow, der geht ja all in. Da scheint ja wirklich unsere Fragen aufzugreifen. Er bleibt aber nicht lange bei dieser Empirie, sondern nennt nur noch mal kurz die Raubkunst. Während wir uns also oben schon fragen, wer sind die Täter, wissen wir es bei dem Thema ganz genau. Denn hier wird auch sozusagen nach dem sehr gegenwärtigen Einstieg noch mal die Geschichte ein bisschen in Anklang gebracht. Es gibt heute eine Sensibilität für Täterschaften und Opfer, die wir lange nicht hatten, denn diese Sachen lagen 100 Jahre im Museum und jetzt plötzlich ist das ein Problem. Es kann sich also nicht nur die Realität ändern, sondern auch, wie beobachten wir Realität? Was problematisieren wir? Was ist im politischen Gespräch? Da denke ich mir, nach einem guten Einstieg wurde sogar das Thema noch gut geöffnet. Es wurden Problematisierungsräume aufgemacht, die jetzt mal zu besprechen sind. Im nächsten Schritt nennt er uns die Politik als Einflugsschneise. Warum das überhaupt interessant ist, wo ich denke, ja, gerade die Politik zielt ja darauf ab, Aushandlungen zu finden, Diskurse zu befrieden, anzuheizen, wie auch immer. Das ist ja der Regulierungsmechanismus für diese Art von Verrechnungsfragen beim Thema Verlust. Nur er nennt uns halt einfach nur das Verlustängste in politischen Arenen und so ausgefochten werden, dass sie politische Agenda prägen, dass wir auch die Zukunft unter Verlust verhandeln. Das stimmt. Wir haben eine junge Generation, die sich vom Verfassungsgericht ein Recht auf Zukunft erkämpft hat. Da ging also etwas verloren. Und hier sehen wir schon, das sind alles Reformulierungen von Phänomen. Also sie wird nicht sozusagen reingestochert und weiterentwickelt und soziologisch ergänzt, sondern wir haben es einfach mit Reformulierung.
Und diese Prinzipien der Reformulierung ziehen sich ja dann durch das gesamte Buch.
Genau. Dann ist es der Modus des Buches und es ist sehr, sehr, sehr schade.
Er ruft sie auch laufend wieder auf. Also wo man es dann alles schon einmal gelesen hat, kommt noch mal das Problem Klimawandel, aber auch die Ungleichheit, aber auch dies. Aber es wird nur aufgerufen bzw. reformuliert. Es werden unendlich lange Aufzählungen gemacht. Also das hat jetzt eben schon, hat man da einen Eindruck von bekommen. Menschen betrauern, wenn jemand stirbt, der ihnen nahesteht. Das würde ihr reichen. Aber dann muss man noch mal sagen, das können Familienmitglieder sein, das können Freunde sein, das können die eigenen Kinder sein, das kann aber auch der Nachbar sein, das kann aber das Volk sein, das einem nahesteht und und und. Diese Art des Schreibens produziert natürlich sehr lange Bücher. Nur frage ich mich, warum sollte ich mich dadurch quälen? Ich kann es gar nicht anders formulieren als so. Er bringt ja dann auch schon auf Seite 20 seine Grundthese. Sowas finde ich ja erst mal gut, wenn man das sagt. Und zwar bezieht er sich auf den zweiten Teil seines Buches. Da sagt er, meine Grundthese will ich hier allerdings schon nennen. Sie lautet, dass die Moderne ein fundamentales Problem mit Verlusterfahrungen haben muss. Und zwar deswegen, weil diese dem für die moderne konstitutiven Fortschrittsglauben widersprechen. In die Moderne ist ein grundlegender Widerspruch zwischen Fortschritt und Verlust, zwischen dem Glauben an den Fortschritt und der Realität von Verlusterfahrungen eingebaut. Dieser Widerspruch lässt den Status von Verlusten prekär werden. Also man versucht dann zum Beispiel auch, Verluste zu ignorieren, versucht sie zu leugnen, versucht sie anderen auszureden, andere neigen zu Überkompensation. Und wie ich das jetzt gerade hier schon erkläre, merke ich, dass ich fast selbst schon so dazu übergehe, immer weiter, immer weiter zusammen und das und das und das gibt es auch noch. Und das führt aber nicht diese Ausdifferenzierung zu einer analytischen Brillanz, sondern es ist dann mal alles ausdifferenziert. Es liegt dann ausdifferenziert vor uns. Wir können uns irgendwo was rausholen. Immer wird man eine schöne Formulierung finden. Nur ist das doch eine Soziologie, die eigentlich darauf abzielt, nur noch sich in Wort geklingelt zu ergehen. Ich würde fast so weit gehen, ja.
Also in diesem Teil, wo er die Fragen des Buches aufwirft, er hat jetzt seine These gelandet, er macht ja auch die Frage ganz klar, was geht hier vor? Fragt er, warum erlangen heute so viele oder so verschiedenartige Verluste Relevanz? Das ist die Frage, von der dieses Buch seinen Ausgang nimmt. So als gäbe es hinter dieser Frage noch was anderes, aber diesen Schritt wird es nicht geben. Und er stellt sich diese Frage, in welchem Verhältnis steht die westliche Moderne zu den Verlusten? Diese Frage verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, denn es geht hier nicht um das Verhältnis von westlicher Moderne und Verlust. Also wenn geht es um das Verhältnis westlicher politischer Programmatik und Verlust? Warum wird uns da in Wahlkämpfen immer versprochen, dass alles nur, wenn es auch die Frage Gewinn ist oder Fortschritt, warum wird nicht offen über Verluste geredet? Er möchte gerne eine nüchterne Analyse bieten, die die Verlusterfahrung, die in der Gesellschaft gemacht wird, beschreibt. Aber es will keiner erhaltlosen Dramatisierung Vorschub leisten. Da habe ich mir dran geschrieben, schade. Denn wenn wir es hier anders formulieren, also wenn wir jetzt reformulieren, was er für ein Angebot gemacht hat, er sagt jetzt einfach Verlust und du hast jetzt den Fortschritt mit reingebracht. Ich glaube, niemand käme von sich aus drauf zu sagen, der Gegenbegriff des Verlusts, die andere Seite der Unterscheidung, ist der Fortschritt. Sondern bei Verlust denkt man an Gewinn.
Gewinn, ja.
Oder irgendetwas, aber nicht an Fortschritt. Und schon diese Konstruktion, finde ich, er erklärt sie ausführlich, wir gehen drauf ein. Merkwürdig.
Jaja, du hast vollkommen recht. Und mir ging es beim Lesen auch immer wieder so. Er bringt alles irgendwann unter den Begriff Verlust. Und wie ich eben sagte, das neue iPhone ist nicht, dass da gleichzeitig ein Verlust mitschwingt, dass das alte iPhone nicht mehr da ist. Der neue Fernseher ist nicht, dass man sagt, ah, das ist aber schade, dass der Verlust sich geht, der andere, weil der nicht mehr so gut ist. Das heißt, der technische Fortschritt erst einmal kann natürlich zu einer Form von Verlust führen, dass man sagt, ja, ich finde in der Welt nicht mehr zurecht. Also wenn ich jetzt auf meinem Bargeld in 20 Jahren noch bestehe, könnte ich Schwierigkeiten bekommen. Und dann ist das eine Verlusterfahrung. Ich frage mich nur, ob man damit weiterkommt, dann mit diesem Punkt. Oder würde man nicht eher mit Verlust und Gewinn rechnen und dann immer fragen, ja, aber was ist der Gewinn? Und da ist ja dann eine Frage, die sich wegen mir anschließt jetzt an die westliche Moderne. Werden noch genügend Gewinne eingefahren? Oder führt das eher dazu, dass wir, das meine ich jetzt ganz wirtschaftlich gesprochen, an einem Punkt sind, wo wir zwar Wachstum haben, aber doch dieses Wirtschaftswachstum nicht im Portemonnaie erleben, wo wir zwar die schnellsten Autos der Welt bauen können, aber zugleich die Klimakatastrophe vor uns haben. Und da müsste man aber dann, glaube ich, wenn man über diese Art der Verluste nachdenkt oder die Fragen von Grenzen des Wachstums oder so etwas, da müsste man aber wirklich mal einen globalen Blick einnehmen. Er markiert zwar, dass er den westlichen Blick hier in erster Linie meint, aber warum geht er dann nicht mal auf etwas anderes ein? Warum sagt man dann nicht mal, ja in Indien wird Verlust anders gerade wahrgenommen. Die haben wahnsinnigen Zugebindungen durch China.
Also ich finde, du hast ja gesagt, die globale Perspektive, ich würde sagen überhaupt eine Perspektive auf die Gegenwart. Humann hat mir heute morgen einen sehr ausführlichen Text Hinweis geschickt auf den neuen Podcast von Adam Twoes. Er meint, das ist die bisher beste Erklärung, warum das mit in Amerika gescheitert ist. So und er führt dann aus Adam Twoes Beschreibe in diesem Podcast. Ich habe es mir kurz angehört und würde sagen, ja, das ist ein genau richtiger Hinweis. Dann können wir alle mal nachgehen. Adam Twoes beschreibt, wie die Investitionspolitik von Biden, dieser, ich meine, der heißt Inflation Reduction Act, aber er war kein Inflation Reduction, sondern er war ein Investment Growth Act, weil er genau die Inflation zu mindern hat er nicht erreicht. Das hat er befördert. So und jetzt wurde ja immer betont, in Amerika sind die ökonomischen Kennziffern alle auf der richtigen Seite. Sie leuchten grün, großes Plus, alles wächst, Wirtschaftswachstum, wie wir es sonst gar nicht kennen, aber es kommt bei den Leuten nicht an. So und hier muss man jetzt, finde ich, mit der korrekten Verlust, Gewinn, Verrechnung eines politischen Programms und dann das politische Publikum, diesen Konnex. Und da kann man unendlich viel beobachten, wenn man das so macht. Also wenn man sich diesen Fokus nimmt, Amerika gewinnt bei allen relevanten Kennziffern, außer bei der Inflation, aber ausgerechnet die Inflation kam beim Wähler an. Die Kennziffern wählen nicht, aber die Wähler wählen. Die Wähler haben gesagt, die Kennziffern sind wir alle egal, ich brauche keinen Stock All-Time-High, ich brauche einfach nur eine billige Butter. So und jetzt haben wir die größte Dramatik Amerikas, weil hier Gewinn- und Verlustrechnung falsch beobachtet wurde, falsch angewandt wurde.
Ganz richtig. Ich will nicht zu selbstreferenziell werden, aber als ich in Düsseldorf den Vortrag hielt, endete ich damit, dass ich zeigte, wie die Reallohnentwicklung war und bezog mich da auf eine Grafik von Tom Krebs und zeigte, wie die Reallöhne zurückgegangen sind, beziehungsweise auch davor nur wenig angestiegen sind. Und dann zeigte ich den MACA World, der 1500 Aktienunternehmen aus 23 Industrieländern abbildet. Also es ist der Index schlechthin, wenn man etwas über die Börse wissen will. Und habe gezeigt, wie der angestiegen ist. Und dann muss man das in ein Verhältnis setzen und genau nach Gewinnen und Verlusten fragen. Und bei dem Einkommen ist der Gewinn nicht hingekommen, bei den Kapitalerträgen sehr wohl.
Und das ist hier zum Beispiel in Deutschland dasselbe, weshalb wir die amerikanische Diskussion einmal sozusagen katapultiert auf diese theoretische grundbegriffliche Ebene, so dass wir sie uns wieder pflücken können, um sie hier anwendbar zu machen. Das hätte man auf drei Seiten in so einem Buch machen müssen. Gerade in dieser Zeit wurde nicht gemacht. Stattdessen bekommen wir nach der Frage des Buchs eine Verortung des Buchs in der Psychoanalyse und der Beobachtung von Pathologien auch in der Soziologie. Und wir bekommen jetzt einen Hinweis, wie er denkt und wie ich sage, denkt so einfach nicht. Also es ist Quatsch. Er möchte nämlich uns den Verlust als in Krisen geht etwas Relevantes verloren. Und warum ist es jetzt nicht der Gewinnen oder sowas, sondern warum ist das so auf sich selber bezogen? Mir geht etwas verloren, was ich schon mal hatte. Und er sagt, ja, weil in der Psychoanalyse und so weiter, wo ich finde, da bedient man sich in dem Moment bitte nicht, in seiner Konzeption, einfach gesagt wird, in der persönlichen Entwicklung gibt es Sprünge, die noch nicht gemacht wurden. Also werden Krisen erfahren, in denen Sachen verlustig gehen, die vorher relevant waren. Da würde ich sagen, ja, es kommt ja später dann drauf, man wird geboren, verliert die Mutter und gewinnt die Welt, wie Mary das jetzt so schön gesagt hat im Büro. Und das sind alles so literarische und sehr inspirative, illustrative, für ein Podcastgespräch genau richtig platzierte Sachen. Aber nicht für einen Soziologie-Professor, der uns Verluste erklärt und das als ich unterstütze hiermit das politische Denken ausflackt.
Mein Eindruck war, hier wird eigentlich mit Hilfe der Soziologie Erbauungsliteratur verfasst.
Genau.
Mal ein bisschen was zu nachdenken, mal über das, was wir ohnehin vorfinden, noch einmal so einmal um die Ecke gedacht, noch mal ein bisschen aufgetröselt, ein bisschen differenzierter gesehen. Aber eigentlich geht es um so eine Erbauung daran, dass, wenn man mal mit der Sprache ins Spielen kommt, man vielleicht ein bisschen näher den Gefühlen kommt, die man so hat und nicht immer artikulieren kann. Aber eine Analyse der Gesellschaft, die die Soziologie ja eigentlich anstrebt, hat nicht vorgenommen. Und deswegen sagte ich eben, die schon genannten Autoren haben versucht, da systematisch heranzugehen. Und ich hätte mir das sehr gewünscht, dass er das tut. Und es gibt ja eine ja verräterische Fußnote, die ich mal vorlesen möchte, die auch vielleicht das Problem dieses Buches ganz deutlich macht. Irgendwo in der Mitte des Buches in einer Fußnote heißt es, um die modernen Verlustpotenzierungen zu verstehen, ist es wichtig, sich aus allzu engen Theoriekursets zu lösen und aus der ganzen Bandbreite gesellschaftstheoretischer Ressourcen zu schöpfen. Es gibt nicht den einen allumfassenden Mechanismus der Verlustpotenzierung, sich ausschließlich mit der marxistischen Kapitalismustheorie und den Wirkungen der entgrenzten Kapitalakkumulation oder mit der Systemtheorie und den nicht intendierten Folgen komplexer Systeme oder mit der kritischen Theorie und den Gewalteffekten der Staates zu beschäftigen, wäre zu kurz gesprungen. Vielmehr gilt es, diese und weitere theoretische Quellen zugleich heranzuziehen. Und dieses Zugleich-Heranziehen findet aber in einer Weise statt, dass ich das alles nebeneinander vorfinde. Es ist wirklich alles in diesem Buch drin und jedes Buch, das sich in den letzten hundert Jahren mit Verlust beschäftigt hat, wird hier einmal kurz aufgerufen. Nur, wenn dann gar nichts damit gemacht wird, würde ich es doch bevorzugen, ich hätte einen Systemtheoretiker oder einen Marxisten, der sagt, Gewinn und Verlust, oder die Systeme sind in der und jener Weise auf Verlust eingestellt. Und dann habe ich damit einen Schlüssel, das ist nicht der Schlüssel für alles, aber eine Schlüssel, um mir die Wirklichkeit aufzuschließen. Hier bekomme ich jetzt ganz viel einfach angeboten, wo ich aber sage, ja, es ist schön, dass es das alles in dieser Welt gibt, und du hast es uns zusammengeführt, aber es kommt nicht eine weitere Ebene der Analyse hinein.
Genau. Die Soziologie ist kein Puzzlespiel, in dem man einfach alle Puzzle-Steine, die man hat, irgendwie unterbringt. Denn wir wissen ja, die Fokussierung kann den Blick erweitern. Die Verengung erweitert, die Komplexitätsreduktion baut gleichzeitig welche auf. Denn ich will das genau aufgreifen, was du meinst, und kurz mal einfach ausmalen, das Bild, also ich mal alles nennen, was er nennt, ausgehend von diesem psychoanalytischen Zugriff, in dem er uns noch, wie eben schon gesagt, so die Krise, die Entwicklung und das. Und dann darauf kommt, dass der kritische Blick richtet sich also meist auf den Mangel an wirklichem Fortschritt, nicht auf den durch den Fortschritt etablierten Mangel oder den Mangel trotz des Fortschritts. Also dieser komplizierte Satz, der aus einer Quelle kommt, die hier nichts zu suchen hat, wird uns dargelegt, um jetzt den Verlust mit dem Fortschritt in eine Unterscheidung zu bringen, die, wie ich finde, nicht aufgeht und auch über diese Umwege nicht gebaut werden kann. Und bevor ich jetzt einen Vorschlag mache, wie das eigentlich viel einfacher und damit weitreichender gemacht werden kann, er nennt aus der Literatur den Fortschrittsdiskurs, denn das ist ja dann das Vehikel, das er braucht. Da ich jetzt den Verlust als Gegenteil vom Fortschritt deklariere, kann ich einfach alles, was jemals Fortschritt im Text hatte, für mich vereinnahmen. Und diese Vereinnahmung ist dann Max Weber, denn der weist auf Entzauberung hin. Georg Simmel, die Tragödie der Kultur. Walter Benjamin's These, dass der Verlust der Aura durch die technisierte Massenkultur, George Lukascht, oder wie er ausgesprochen wird, Annahme einer transcendentalen Obdachlosigkeit, die begegnet uns später häufiger, weil er das auch einen witzigen Begriff findet, okay. Martin Heideggers, Ontologie des Seins, oder der Seinsvergessenheit. Richard Sennetz, Verfall und das Ende des öffentlichen Lebens. Alasdair McIntyre, Verlust der Tugend in der Moderne. Ich würde jetzt einfach sagen, alles mal aussortieren. Wir beobachten oder wir stellen eine Beobachtung vor, die erstmal jeder teilt. Und jeder Leser wäre, glaube ich, einverstanden, wenn man sagt, Verlust ist schon ein politischer Begriff oder ein psychoanalytischer oder was auch immer. Soziologisch beginnen wir bei der Veränderung. Wir haben erstmal nur eine Veränderung. Und wenn man es noch nüchtern haben will, sagt man einfach Variation. Wir beobachten eine Variation. Es liegt ein Kosmos an Handlungsmöglichkeiten da. Und es wird erkennbar nicht gemacht, was wir immer schon gemacht haben. Also wird nicht einfach durchselegiert. Ah ja, sieben Uhr klingelt der Wecker, also stehe ich auf. Sondern nein, es wird eine Variation ausgewählt. Ein bisher nur möglicher Handlungsalternative wird plötzlich aktualisiert. Ich bleibe fünf Minuten länger liegen. Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Mal gucken, was passiert. Also man beobachtet erstmal ganz neutral eine Veränderung. Und wenn sie dann familiär, freundschaftlich, politisch, therapeutisch, ökonomisch, wie auch immer, verrechnet wird, also wenn dann sie folgenreich angeschlossen wird, dann klassifizieren wir sie als Veränderung. Da wird aus der Variation eine Veränderung. Und wie sie verrechnet wird, ab dann machen wir einen Verlustskurs. Dann hat man das fundiert. Dann weiß man, worüber man redet. Und dann kann man von da aus alle Diskussionen führen. Aber hier so ein breites, Max Weber hat ja auch schon von der Entzauberung durch Fortschritt gesprochen. Und ich habe ja vorher über psychoanalytische Umwege den Fortschritt mit dem Verlust in die Unterscheidung gebracht. Also ist das jetzt eine Literatur, die mir weiterhilft?
Generell wird man, wann immer man sich mit irgendwas beschäftigt, feststellen, dass da was mit Verlusten vorkommt.
Genau.
Und so macht er auch…
Teufelsküche nennt man das eigentlich.
Auflistungen von Filmen oder Romanen, die sich mit Verlusten beschäftigen. Wo ich dann denke, ja, aber warum gerade die? Also warum wird Madame Bovary genannt? Ist das Verlust der bürgerlichen Ehe? Ja, okay. Febriest hätte man auch nennen können. Buddenbrucks, da geht eine Familie unter. Da geht also ein Unternehmen verlustig. Wird also auch aufgegriffen. Ja, ich kann jetzt eine Million Bücher aufschreiben, wo endlich jeder was verliert, der Partner stirbt oder sonst was ist. Das ist das Leben.
Genau, aber damit entwertet man den Grundbegriff, weil man illustriert ihn einfach nur, aber man öffnet ihn nicht als Erklärung, als Folie für irgendwas, als Konzept. Und das ist eben, wenn er so begeistert ist von Obdachlosigkeit, transsidentale Obdachlosigkeit. Dieses Buch leidet an Konzept-Obdachlosigkeit. Es ist konzeptionslose Obdachlosigkeit, irgendwo eine intellektuelle Obdachlosigkeit. Denn in dem Moment, wo er dieses riesige Feld an, die haben auch schon alle über Fortschritt und Tier und Nezauberung und was auch immer nachgedacht, der schließt er dann an, indem er das Buch nochmal startet. Es ist ja eigentlich schon gestartet. Und dann erklärt uns plötzlich, das Buch behandelt nacheinander drei Fragen. Erstens, was sind Verluste? Und wie lassen sie sich als soziales Phänomen begreifen? Zweitens, in welchem Verhältnis steht die moderne Gesellschaft zu Verlusten? Diese Frage verstehe ich nicht und ich bleibe auch dabei. Die versteht man nicht. Und ich will es so deutlich sagen, damit Leser, die sowas lesen und sagen, das verstehe ich nicht, von mir hören, ich glaube, da gibt es nichts zu verstehen. Das ist einfach ein totaler Nonsens, den ich schreibe. Drittens, was verändert sich mit den Verlusten in der spätmodernen Gegenwart? Was verändert sich mit den Verlusten? Die Verluste sind schon eine Veränderung. Es ist ein Modus der Beobachtung, Veränderung als Verlust zu deklarieren. Und es lädt zur Frage ein, wie werden sie verrechnet? So macht das Sinn, aber nicht andersrum. Wie er das aufzieht.
Wenn du jetzt auch wie ich beklagst, dass es da nicht das Konzept gibt, das man aber eigentlich benötigen würde, dann kann man ja sagen, wenn man ein bisschen böse ist, dass das Buch, das vom Verlust handelt, selber etwas verloren hat. Nämlich das Konzept, oder es war nie da. Beziehungsweise ist dann dieses Buch, wenn man so möchte, wirklich Phänomen seiner Zeit und zeigt nicht das Phänomen seiner Zeit, sondern ist das Phänomen seiner Zeit, wenn wir hier eigentlich ein uns orientierungslos machen, das Buch sehen oder ein Buch, das ja so orientierungslos ist wie die meisten von uns. Aber vielleicht kommt die Orientierungslosigkeit auch gerade daher, wenn man einen sehr allgemeinen Begriff, nämlich den des Verlusts nimmt und ihn nicht versucht, zu definieren, zu verengen, sondern den Begriff in seiner ganzen Fülle gerne ausschöpfen will, dann kommt man an den Punkt, in dem es alles irgendwie stimmt und nicht stimmt. Also wenn ich jetzt ein Buch über Liebe schreibe, dann, nein, bleiben wir noch mal bei dem Thema, wenn ich jetzt ein Buch über Gewinne schreibe, könnte ich, ich könnte dasselbe Buch über Gewinne schreiben und könnte sagen, ja, Max Weber hat sich mit Gewinnen beschäftigt, die Zugewinne, die durch Modernisierung und Bürokratisierung kommen. Walter Benjamin hat sich mit Gewinnen beschäftigt, denn es ging nicht nur um den Auraverlust, sondern auch um die demokratisierende Möglichkeit des technischen Fortschritts, ein Zugewinnen. Wir können jetzt die ganze Geschichte auch laufend als eine Gewinnengeschichte erzählen und sagen, ja, und diese Gewinne beschleunigen und intensivieren sich dann nochmal, besonders in der Spätmoderne, das hängt damit in Dortmund zusammen. Gewinne sind aber auch im ganz persönlichen Sinne der Herzensentfaltung, was auch immer. Ja, so können wir immer weitergehen. Nur habe ich dann ganz viele Worte aufgeschrieben, um etwas zu gewinnen, zu sagen, habe aber dadurch, dass ich es nicht verengt habe, also verengt im Sinne von präzisiert habe, eigentlich nichts gemacht, außer jetzt so ein Überangebot an Interpretationsvarianten, Möglichkeiten, aus denen man sich was herauspicken darf, wenn man möchte. Aber das ist ja genau das, was unsere Gegenwart schon bietet. Man kann es da, sich selbst erfüllen im Yogakurs, du kannst aber auch da in die Kirche gehen, du kannst aber auch an Elon Musks Freiheitsversprechen glauben. Ja, das ist ja dieses überbordende Sinnenangebot, das nicht mehr holistisch sein kann. Und jetzt haben wir so ein Buch, das uns auch überbordend anbietet, wie man einen Begriff, den man so kennt und dann doch nicht ganz kennt, immer weiter auffächern kann.
In diesem Bereich des Textes, wo wir jetzt sind, wo also die Grundthese des Buches noch mal genannt wird, die Moderne hat ein fundamentales Problem mit Verlusterfahrung, weil sie unserem Fortschrittsglauben widersprechen. Und wie ich ja sage, das ist schon, so zu sagen, hilft uns schon nicht weiter. Und du fragst jetzt auch, was machen wir denn mit eigentlich? Eigentlich spannte er den selben Bogen wie Blüte an. Er sagt, Verluste hängen von Wahrnehmungen ab. Jemand muss einen Verlust erfahren und darunter leiden. Da würde ich sagen, okay, das öffnet dann auch das Tür der Psychoanalyse, denn die haben sehr viele Erfahrungen mit Verlusterfahrung. Wenn schon die Geburt ein Verlusterfahrung ist, dann ist man da genau richtig. Und dann sagt er, diese Verlust Wahrnehmung steht also in enger Verbindung zu Deutungsmustern, Diskursen, Narrativen. Dann klassifiziert er die einfach als soziale Phänomene und öffnet damit den individuell erfahrenen Verlust, den ich ja genauso gut mit mir verhandeln könnte, zu einem politischen Problem. So. Und dann schreibt er unten, also ein Stück tiefer, der Verlust durchkreuzt das Fortschrittsversprechen. Und da würde ich sagen, das stimmt. Das haben wir ja bei Blüthorn auch schon gelesen. Jemand macht eine Verlusterfahrung, weil in einer sich verändernden Welt etwas verloren geht. Und vielleicht, das habe ich ja dann kritisiert, kann man sogar so weit gehen, dass derjenige, der die Veränderung forciert, weil er sagt, ich bin ein moderner Mensch, ich möchte die Veränderung, er wirkt damit den Verlust der anderen. Und da würde ich sagen, ja genau, also genauso kann man es beobachten. Nur dafür braucht man bisher keine hunderten Seiten Text, um einfach zu sagen, es gibt einen Fortschritt. Er heißt E-Mobilität. Die Fabriken sind viel einfacher. Die Materialien, die zu verwenden sind, sind viel einfacher. Der E-Motor selbst ist so klein, der passt in den Autoreifen. Die einzige Frage, die noch ist, was ist die Energiequelle? Der Akku mit irgendwelchen Technologien aus irgendwelchen Minen, wo Kinder arbeiten oder der Wasserstoff in der Brennstoffzelle, was sehr kompliziert mit Betankung ist und so weiter. Also, das sind so kleine Fragen, die man noch hat. Aber man kann erst mal bei der Land sitzen und sagen, und das hat ja Herbert Diess dann gemacht als ehemaliger VW-Chef, also ein E-Motor hat 100 Teile und ein Verbrenner halt 700. Das ist also komplizierter. In dem Moment, wo wir also E-Mobilität als Fortschritt deklarieren, geht uns VW verloren und damit beobachten wir volkswirtschaftliche Einschnitte, die uns alle betreffen und die natürlich die Politik in Auffallungen bringen. Nur um das zu beschreiben, kann man keinem, der sich dafür interessiert, irgendwie noch mal erklären, was das hat, also was hat das jetzt mit Walter Benjamin zu tun, sondern nein, wir wissen genau, worum es hier geht. Und jetzt kommt so eine Art Verschleierungstaktik von Reckwitz. Er nennt einfach keine Namen. Er macht sich nicht die Finger schmutzig mit Namen von Politikern, Namen von Firmen, Namen von, was kann man so an Besitz auftürmen, was betrifft unseren Alltag, weil er genau weiß, sobald ich Namen nenne, wird jedem klar, und wozu brauche ich jetzt dieses Gerüst darüber? Ja, wozu brauche ich dieses Gerüst?
Ich bin ja ein Freund der Theorie, wie du weißt, aber sie muss für sich auch Sinn ergeben, die Theorie, also dass die Theorie mir einen Mehrwert bietet. Es geht nicht darum zu sagen, ich habe hier eine Wirklichkeit, ist mir aber eigentlich zu einfach. Bitte die Theorie verkompliziere es und lass es wohl klingen.
Eine Heuristik wäre schön. Und eine Heuristik, die so einfach zu verstehen ist, dass der Autor sich traut, sie auszusprechen, wäre sogar noch besser. Dann nimmt man den Leser einfach an die Hand. Und das ist eigentlich der größte Mangel an der gegenwärtigen Soziologie, weshalb sie auch wirklich mitschuldig ist. Ich meine, die Soziologie wurde bewusst erfunden, um zu beschreiben und nächste Schritte mitzuplanen. Und das leistet sie heute nicht. Er kommt hier mit, die Verlusterfahrung wird überhaupt nur erkennbar, weil sie narrativ eingewoben wird. Wie schön wäre es denn, wenn die Soziologie Angebote zum Denken macht, die auch mal narrativ eingeworben werden, sodass wir nicht immer nur feststellen, Kamala Harris hat die amerikanische Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen, weil niemand verstande, warum man sie wählen sollte. Donald Trump hat einfach gesagt, ich bin der Change-and-Hope-Kandidat. Also nur, bevor man eine inhaltliche aus, nur weil Trump ein Narrativ hatte, hat er gewonnen, können wir heute sagen. Hätte man nicht Harris auch einfach mal soziologisch beraten können, du brauchst ein Narrativ. Nenne ich einfach nur Grundbegriffe. Baue es nicht nur über die Verteufelung des anderen, rede auch über dein Angebot und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Soziologie, wie man hier an solchen Werken sieht, traut sich nichts zu. Sie macht sich die Finger nicht schmutzig. Sie nennt keine Namen. Sie traut sich die Gegenwart nicht zu, sondern geht konzeptionell immer zurück zu Max Weber. Und das hilft uns einfach nicht weiter.
Ja, oder man bekommt das gesagt, was doch allgemein bekannt ist, nur dann nochmal anders formuliert. Das selbst ist nämlich keine fest umrissene objektive Entität, sondern konstituiert sich, ob nun als Subjekt oder als kollektive Einheit, prozesshaft und fortlaufend im Vollzug seiner sozialen Praxis, in den Wiederholungen wie in den Brüchen, die diese enthält. In mitten dieser Praktiken finden fortlaufende Interpretationen statt, in denen das Selbst sich auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise deutet, also in sinnhafter Reflexivität, sich als ein Selbst mit bestimmten realen oder idealen Eigenschaften versteht und zu seiner Umwelt ins Verhältnis setzt. Wir stellen also fest, der Mensch lebt in einer Gesellschaft.
Und das sagt, das schreibt ein Soziologe.
Das sage ich jetzt am Ende, um zu sagen, wofür die Worte.
Der sagt, ich publiziere Bücher, weil ich die Soziologie in den Dienst der Gesellschaft stellen möchte. Solche Sachen, und das Buch besteht nur aus solchen Sachen, sind nicht zu vermitteln. Wolfgang selber könnte die jetzt nicht, ohne nochmal vorzulesen, jemand in einem Küchengespräch erklären, außer halt, dass das sich selbst konstituiert und so. Man erinnert sich an diese Bruchstücke und sich an das ist so klar.
Ja, es ist so klar, weil man sagt, man ist in einer Gesellschaft, man ist in einer Beziehung zu den Menschen, die einen umgeben. Auch die Geschichte, die man erlebt hat, ist in einem die Identität prägt einen mit. Die Geschichte, die man von sich selbst erzählt, ist auch wiederum prägend, die erzählt man anderen und, und, und. Also so kann man das jetzt immer weiterleiern. Und ich habe dann an etwas gedacht, und es ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen unfair, aber ich will es trotzdem sagen. Und ich war kurz davor, es mitzubringen. Ich habe dann gedacht, ne, ich kaufe das jetzt nicht. Jakuda Marinic hat ja ein Buch auch geschrieben. Und dieses Buch heißt Sanfte Radikalität. Wir merken schon, das ist also der Versuch, weil sehr viele Bücher jetzt gerade irgendwas mit radikalem Titel haben, da auch anzudocken. Und dann liest man, ich habe nur das Vorwort gelesen, man liest dieses Vorwort. Und es ist nur ein Wort geklingelt, nur ein, ich bin auf, der Mensch ist auf dem Weg, ich bin auf dem Weg und wir befragen uns und ich frage mich nochmal so und und und und und. Also es geht immer weiter. Vielleicht lese ich doch noch einen Abschnitt, den ich mir rausgesucht habe, gleich vor. Und da ist einfach interessant zu sehen, dass wir nur noch eine Produktion haben von Sätzen, die für ein gewisses Publikum gemacht sind, die eigentlich nur in ihrer eigenen Orientierungslosigkeit noch mal so eine Stütze brauchen, die gut klingt. Also früher hätte man vielleicht dann gesagt, wir singen mal zusammen ein Lied oder so. Und das ist so ein neuer Wortgottesdienst, der da stattfindet.
Ja, das ist nicht neu. Das Phänomen, für das haben wir neuerdings einen Begriff. Denn wir sprechen ja jetzt, wo die neuen Chatbots kommen, die sich auf uns einstellen, von Companion AI. Und das ist Companion Literatur. Sie begleitet dich, aber sie bringt dich nicht aus dem Tritt. Sie nimmt dich an die Hand, aber du behältst die Führung. Sie begleitet dich therapeutisch. Sie sagt dir noch mal, du machst alles richtig. Und das finde ich hier in diesem Buch auch interessant, denn plötzlich, sage ich so aus Lesersicht, wir haben ja nun alles gelesen, zum Beispiel Steffen Maus Arenen Soziologie, und wir haben sie als sehr gut empfunden, weil er die Arenen aus der Empirie gewonnen hat. Er hat sich einfach Fokusgruppen geschnappt, hat gesagt, ich rede jetzt mit euch und aus diesen Gesprächen gewinne ich Arenen, um dann Politikern zu erklären, wo sie Arenengrenzen überschreiten, mit den Fragestellungen der einen Arena auf Affektivitäten der anderen Arena oder wie auch immer, wie sie sich da verirren. Also kommt hier auch plötzlich der Begriff Arena ins Spiel. Soziale Verlust Arena. Und jetzt können wir alle mal, während ich das sage, überlegen, ist das jetzt aus Empirie gewonnen? Die eine Arena heißt Zeitlichkeit.
Ich dachte es erst.
Die andere Arena heißt Narrativität und dann Affektivität. Das ist nicht aus der Empirie gewonnen. Also das, was wir so geschätzt haben am Begriff der Arena, der ja vor Steffen Mauer schon präsent, aber nicht so prominent, also auch im politischen Gespräch behandelt wurde, die Arena des Diskurses, der begegnet uns hier auch, aber aus der völlig falschen Richtung. Willst du uns Marinic vorlesen?
Ja, also ich lese jetzt was aus dem Vorwort vor. Da heißt es, auch gegen dieses Gefühl der Ohnmacht schreibe ich dieses Buch. Für die Tage nach den selbst vergewissernden Demonstrationen, in denen es darum geht, die gezeigte Haltung in demokratische Realität zu verwandeln. Es ist höchste Zeit, die bestehenden Strukturen wieder für mehr Demokratie zu nutzen, zu lernen, dass wir in Diskussionen nur einen kleinen Teil leisten können, der jedoch ohne das hoffnungsvolle Handeln verpuffen wird, weil antidemokratische Kräfte eine konzentrierte Zusammenarbeit an den Tag legen, die mehr als die Machtübernahme zum Ziel hat, sondern die Macht missbrauchen will, um demokratische Strukturen auszuhöhlen. Wie gelingt in diesen Zeiten nicht nur der Erhalt des Gestern, sondern doch noch ein Wandel in eine Zukunft, die es mehr Menschen ermöglicht, am demokratischen Prozess teilzuhaben. Ich möchte die Erfahrungen, die ich machen konnte, teilen, die Zweifel beschreiben, die Frustrationen, aber auch das, was man lernen kann in solchen Auseinandersetzungen und wie man beharrlich bleibt, bis der Wandel einsetzt. Weiter heißt es dann, etwas weiter runter, in einer funktionierenden Demokratie wird dabei niemals der radikalste Erfolg haben. Wer in einer Demokratie seine Vorstellungen auf dem Marktplatz der Ideen durchsetzen möchte, muss lernen, seine Ideen für möglichst viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger zugänglich zu machen. Das gelingt nicht, indem ich andere anschreie und ihnen ein schlechtes Gewissen mache. Es gelingt nicht rein pädagogisch und schon gar nicht dogmatisch. Es ist ein Lernprozess, in dem ich die Idee nie wieder aus dem Auge verliere und doch immer neue Mittel finde und neue Wege, Demokratie zu verstehen und zu leben. Ich wurde sanfter auf diesem Weg, aber meine Vorstellungen von einer gerechteren Gesellschaft nicht weniger radikal.
Ja, sehr gut. Allerbester Literatur für einen, keine Ahnung für was.
Ich würde jetzt einfach gerne wissen, was ist mit Gerechtigkeit gemeint? Superreiche besteuern, 15 Euro Mindestlohn, alle sollen gleich viel verdienen, Mietpreisbremse, ich würde es gerne wissen.
Es ist im Grunde die selbe Anlage des Textes, wie bei Reckwitz, nur mit anderen Mitteln, anderen Konzepten, anderen Narrationsentscheidungen.
Also ein bisschen persönlicher, noch ein bisschen mehr Gefühl.
Aber wir haben es wirklich erheblich mit Literatur zu tun, die zu nichts mehr führt, also die uns nirgendwo hinführt. Die einfach companionmäßig unseren Gemütszustand so begleitet.
Du hast jetzt gerade Stop Generating gerufen. Die schreiben das alles selbst. Ich will jetzt hier nicht, dass jemand den Eindruck gewinnt, ich will denen unterstellen, dass die das haben generieren lassen. Das ist ganz im Gegenteil. Aber es ist vielleicht so interessant, so eine Gleichzeitigkeit, dass wir einmal diese AIs haben, die das jetzt so können. Und aber auch zugleich ganz viele Autoren haben, die so gerne schreiben wollen.
Ja, also ich warte im Grunde auf die Weihnachtsansprache. Denn das fällt wirklich zusammen dann.
Wir könnten ja schon mal Claude oder so bitten, eine Weihnachtsansprache, die tragen wir dann hier vor. Und dann machen wir die von Steinmeier.
Wir machen ein Claude-Project und geben die Transkripte der 30 letzten Weihnachtsansprachen da rein. Mit Jahreszahl. So dass ja auch die Entwicklungsgeschichte der Weihnachtsansprache. Dann generieren wir eine für 2024, posten die einen Tag vorher und dann gleichen wir ab. Und ich denke, wir werden die Companion Weihnachtssprache bekommen, die wir vorher vermuten, dass es nicht wird. Und so ist das hier auch. Wir haben hier Literatur, die uns begleitet. Denn uns wird jetzt die Arena vorgestellt, die Verlust Arenen. Diese drei, Zeitlichkeit, Narrativität, Affektivität. Und wir alle verstehen doch, dass wir eine Vorstellung von zeitloser Stabilität haben, der wir irgendwie so affektiv gegenüberstehen. Also wir haben so, es ist schon schön, wenn Stabilität ist. Irgendwann sagt er. Dann eine einseitige Vorstellung von Kultur als System, von Wissen und Argument. Also es wäre doch schön, wenn man versteht, was der andere will. Und jetzt wundern wir uns darüber, dass offenbar sehr viele Leute verstanden haben, was Donald Trump wollte. Aber das, was wir nicht verstehen an Donald Trump, haben die halt besonders verstanden. Also es scheint ein gutes Alignment dazu zu geben. Und Affektivität. Nun ja, wir haben doch alle eine Vorstellung von, wir sind von Gefühlen gekleidet. Wir sind kein rational man. Ja. Also das ergibt wirklich keinen Mehrwert, uns darüber aufzuklären. Alles für sich. Dass wir eigentlich stabilisieren wollen, dass wir gerne Argumente haben, jemanden verstehen. Dass es schon ganz gut ist, wenn die Grammatik stimmt. Auf die haben wir uns geeinigt, auch die inhaltliche Grammatik. Und dass wir auch alle Rücksicht darauf nehmen, dass wir Menschen mit Gefühlen sind. Das hat uns ja Marijanic gerade vorgeführt. Nur weil wir Menschen mit Gefühlen sind, wird es ja so.
Weiter differenziert, zum Beispiel geht es dann um das Gefühl Wut. Wut kann sich in Empörung verwandeln. Die Empörung unterscheidet sich in zweierlei Hinsicht von der Wut. Und ich will das jetzt gar nicht weiter vorlesen, sondern sagen, warum eigentlich zweierlei Hinsicht? Warum nicht in dreierlei oder vierlei Hinsicht? Also das sind ja einfach solche Überlegungen. Man sitzt da, schreibt einen Text und sagt, ja Wut und Empörung hängen irgendwie zusammen, sind aber anders. Worin unterscheiden sie sich? Ja, es gibt zwei Unterscheidungen. Dann heißt es, zum einen ist die Empörung mit einem moralischen Gefühl verbunden und das gegen eine gerechte Ordnung verstoßen wurde und man selbst oder andere unfair behandelt wurden. Ja, würde ich sagen, ja, aber das kann ja bei Wut auch genauso sein. Also ich kann das auch umdrehen. Zum anderen enthält sich die Empörungsreaktion in der Regel der nackten Gewalt und greift eher zu Antworten im Rahmen der sozialen Regeln. Ist das so? Also wer empört es, schlägt nicht. Wer wütend es, schlägt eher. Hätte ich gerne eine genaue Auskunft drüber.
Naja, das ist ja also klar, genau. Aber erreicht es dir nicht, dass es konzeptionell unter Prozessierung und Praxis verbucht. Weil das ist ja sein Angebot.
Ja.
Wut wird ausgelebt. Ja, weil es eine Verzeitlichung, also Prozesse gab, in denen sich das aufstaute. Verlusterfahrungen wurden gemacht. In dem Moment, wo etwas verloren geht, merkt man, dass man dem mehr anhing als vorher. Also es kann sich sogar nochmal steigern. Die Verlusterfahrung kann sozusagen wachsen. Und da wir ja gefühlvolle Menschen sind, die mit der Welt in Rückkopplung stehen, breiten wir das aus in eine Praktik. Und dann habe ich mir dazu wirklich nur Teufels Küche als Anmerkung drüber geschrieben, wenn er auf Doing Loss zu sprechen kommt. Wir haben den Handlungsbegriff hier schon mal in die Mangel genommen. Mit der einfachen Frage, was ist eine beobachtete Duldung? Jemand handelt nicht, sollte aber unserer Meinung nach, können wir ihm einfach unsere Erwartung einimpfen, wie auch immer das funktionieren soll, sodass er plötzlich ausgehend von einer fremden Erwartung, die plötzlich seine eigene ist, sein Nichthandeln, feststellt, überhaupt erst mal erkennen und dann klassifiziert als ich hätte aber handeln sollen und dadurch ging etwas verloren. Ja, also da sind wir wirklich in Teufelsküche. Da sage ich, stopp, sorry, wir müssen jetzt hier auf die Systemtheorie umschwenken. Wir brauchen Kommunikationsbegriff. Die Beobachtung ist entscheidend, aber nicht die Beobachtung abgeleitet aus einer Intention, die wir gar nicht kennen können, weil wir keinen Zugriff auf die Psyche haben und so weiter und so fort. Also die Duldung bringt den ganzen Handlungsbegriff ins Wangen kennen und so können wir ein bis hierhin sowieso schon konzeptionell in der Obdachlosigkeit verfangenes Konstrukt wie Verlust, das nun ganz klar auf Erwartung, Handeln so abstellt und nur dadurch ist es politisch relevant, können wir jetzt nicht noch so ein Doing-Loss unterwerfen. Also einer, wenn der Autor selbst keinen deutschen Begriff dafür hat, in den deutschen Text dann plötzlich auf Doing-Loss zu sprechen kommt, dann ist das schon verdächtig. So geht das einfach nicht.
Und das hat er ja laufend drin.
Ja, und so geht es die ganze Zeit. Er macht eine Anmerkung, die ich dann auch interessant finde, aber nur, weil sie aus viel relevanteren literarischen Angeboten der Soziologie bekannt ist, nämlich zum Thema Liebe. Warum Liebe weh tut, was bei Liebe verloren geht und so weiter von Eva Illouz, die nämlich sagt, manchmal geht beim Thema Verlust nicht einfach nur der Partner verloren, sondern auch der Alltag, den man mit dem Partner hatte, die Erinnerungen, die nämlich jetzt umgedeutet werden und damit auch ein Stück Selbstbild. So, nur das hat halt Eva Illouz schon ganz wunderbar und finde ich auch abschließend und für alle Zeit gültig beschrieben, denn so wie der Mensch vor 300.000 Jahren schon Proteine brauchte, um zu überleben, ist genau dieses Prinzip in der Moderne gesteigert worden, trat also besonders hervor und dann gibt es bestimmte Stressmerkmale durch Kapitalisierung und was auch immer. Also diese Bücher sind halt aus Gründen jetzt geschrieben, aber sie treffen so ein zeitloses Phänomen, warum er das jetzt noch mal ohne einfach mit einem klaren Verweis auf, also warum kommt Eva Ilu es einfach nicht in der Literaturliste vor, die er empfiehlt, wo man das auch schon mal findet. Das finde ich halt dann wieder ärgerlich, weil wenn so hochklassische, ich meine nicht hochklassisch im Sinne von klassisch wichtig, sondern so gut gelungen Literatur da liegt zu einem Verlustthema, kann man das ruhig mal nennen. Auch um dem Leser etwas an die Hand zu geben, wo man, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, weitergehen kann.
Und sonst ist ja das, was er zu Liebe zu sagen hat, auch wieder das, was man sich denken kann. Also wo Beziehungen zum Beispiel sehr instrumentell angegangen werden, wo man Zweckbeziehungen eingeht, da ist der Verlust emotional nicht besonders stark. Also wenn jetzt die Autowerkstatt, zu der ich immer fahre, schließt, dann fahre ich zu einer anderen Autowerkstatt fahren und ich werde nicht weinen. Wenn ich aber jetzt die Liebe meines Lebens verliere, dann ist also die emotionale Reaktion hoch und dann sagt er ja, die romantische Liebe bringt eine hohe Verlustgefahr mit sich. Und ich denke mir, ja, natürlich.
Schon, dass er bei diesen Textstellen über Liebe vom subjektiven, also vom subjektiv Liebenden spricht, statt einfach zu sagen Menschen. Ja, weil das ist ja gemeint. Also warum muss man vom Subjekt der Liebe sprechen? Das ist mir alles zu unpassend.
Wir wissen doch, also ich glaube, das Buch funktioniert dann auch deshalb im journalistischen Diskurs relativ gut, weil es alles ja schon mal so da war. Also wir haben ein Buch über die Multi-Options-Gesellschaft schon über 20 Jahre alt. Und da zeigt sich ja schon also in dieser Multi-Option, steckt also drin, dass man sich entscheiden muss. Das bedeutet aber auch, wenn ich mich für eines entscheide, habe ich mich für das andere alles nicht entschieden. Das wird dann dazu führen, dass man sich immer wieder die Frage stellt, wie er sagt, was wäre wenn. Das kennen wir wiederum alle. Man kann das dann mit anderen Freiheitsversprechen, mit dem Erschöpften selbst, das wird hier auch einmal kurz zitiert von Allen Ehrenberg, auch ein 20 Jahre altes Buch, in Assoziation setzen. Aber das ist ja alles dann so irgendwie da. Und wir merken ja jetzt so dieses Zeitalter, in dem wir leben oder in dem wir jetzt so seit 30, 40 Jahren leben im Westen. Da ist es oft so, dass wir keine allgemeingültigen Antworten mehr bekommen, dass wir immer noch eine andere Möglichkeit hätten, damit auch spielen. Dadurch wird das brüchig, was vorher fest war. Am Ende ist das aber auch nur nochmal diese Bestätigung, die zitiert er auch an einer Stelle von Marx und Engels, dass im modernen Kapitalismus alles Stehende und Ständische verdampft. Aber das kann doch jetzt nicht das Einzige sein, was man dann aus so einem Buch mitbekommt, außer dass man dann nochmal aufgeschlüsselt bekommt, wie dann zum Beispiel narrative Relativierungen von Verlusten aussehen, oder wie der Umgang mit Verlusten sein kann. Also dass man zum Beispiel jemandem nicht zugesteht, einen Verlust zu empfinden, wenn zum Beispiel Ostdeutsche zu nostalgisch sind. Oder dann gibt es den Preis des Fortschritts, der kompensieren soll, dass es da Verluste gibt. Oder es gibt den Verlust, der als Abweichung markiert wird. Das sind nur die Ausnahmen. Allgemein geht es allen besser. Ja, das mag ja alles sein. Aber ich erlebe ja eigentlich ein Buch, das ich als vielleicht endlose Liste auf Listung beschreiben möchte.
Wir können ja kurz abbiegen bei einem Textteil, der für uns ja interessant ist. Denn du hast jetzt die Wut schon genannt. Die ist ja sozusagen eine politische Einflugschneise, die es dann auch für Journalisten interessant ist. Macht, warum sind die Aussies so wütend oder wie auch immer. Und auch hier wieder eine Liste. Trauer, Angst, Wut und Empörung. Die Trauer richtet sich zurück bei einer Verlusterfahrung. Die Angst richtet sich nach vorn. Also es gibt ja durchaus Denkangebote. Wir kommen nachher auf eins zu sprechen. In Amerika die Wut der Amerikaner als Trauer, um das zu sehen, von dem Donald Trump verspricht, ich kann es euch wiederbringen. Great again. Also wir waren also mal great. Die Frage, wann war es denn great, kann dann keiner so richtig beantworten. Aber dieses Blick nach vorn, Blick zurück. Also die Trauer der einen, die sich in Wut umschlägt, ist die Angst der anderen nach vorne. Was passiert denn jetzt mit Trump? So, also in dem Punkt schön und gut. Und dann kommt er nämlich auf die Figur des dritten zu sprechen. Denn wenn wir schon so im politischen Felde sind, können wir uns ja fragen, was ist eigentlich das Subjekt des Verlusts? Also nicht das Objekt, was geht verloren, sondern wem geht etwas verloren? Und dann eine schöne Unterscheidung. Nicht neu, aber kann man jetzt sagen, okay bei Reckwitz kann man so nachlesen, dass wir es sozusagen von gestandenen Soziologen haben. Die Unterscheidung von Opfer und Verlierer. Ein Verlierer verliert einfach etwas, versucht es vielleicht sogar zu verheimlichen, weil es ja blöd, dass man jetzt ein bisschen weniger wert ist als vor dem Verlust. Dem Opfer wird aber etwas genommen. Es ist ein Aktiv, es gibt also einen Täter. Der Täter ist zugleich ein Schuldiger. Also diese politische Zurechnung von Verlust auf einen Täter, finde ich, kann durchaus Wert eines eigenen Buches sein. Denn das ist das, was uns interessiert.
Die soziologische Arbeit, der ist interessant. Genau, der ist interessant. Denn wenn ich jetzt bei diesem, ich verliere einfach irgendetwas und es gibt aber keinen Täter, dann bin ich ja bei ganz vielen Schicksalsfragen. Ich kann morgen meine Gesundheit verlieren. Ja, ist das dann ein Thema, das man zusammenbinden sollte, damit, dass jemand aus seiner Wohnung rausfliegt, weil er sich die Miete nicht leisten kann? Nein, das führt nicht weiter. Also das, ich glaube, das ist das Problem, dass hier so viel anthropologische Konstanten, die einfach existent sind, vermischt werden mit gesellschaftlich gemachtem. Und so ist alles irgendwie Verlust. Nur gegen einen gewissen Verlust kann ich mich nicht wehren. Und da sagt er auch zu Recht, die Moderne hat ein Problem mit diesen Verlusten, versucht den Tod klein zu halten, nicht stattfinden zu lassen, unsichtbar zu halten. Also das, was nicht verfügbar ist, dass man nicht sieben Leben gleichzeitig leben kann und und und. Das ist erst mal so da, das ist gegeben. Und der Tod ist eine Präsenz, die nicht aufzulösen ist. Deswegen wird er gerade, wo alles verfügbar scheint, wo man her der Lage, jederzeit zu sein glaubt, als Skandal angesehen. Alles richtig. Aber wenn wir dann zugleich von den anderen Verlusten reden, zum Beispiel wie ein industrieller Wandel dazu führt, dass eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit entsteht, dann sind wir auf einem ganz anderen Terrain. Da sind wir beim gesellschaftlich gemachten. Und das muss auch dann anders behandelt werden, als der Verlust, dass dir die liebe Tante gestorben ist.
Also hier finde ich auch, sollte soziologisch nachgearbeitet werden, denn dieses Vierfelder Prinzip, okay, es gibt so auf der Opferseite, auf der Verliererseite viele Menschen, die man so beobachten kann, weil sie häufig als Wähler auftreten. Und dann gibt es aber zwei Formen der dritten Figuren, nämlich der Täter, also dem etwas zugeschrieben wird als Tat, wegen die habe ich jetzt verloren, und den etwas neutraleren Beobachter, der ja auch ganz häufig in der Politik als der große andere immer adressiert wird, wenn auf Twitter irgendwelcher, und dann mischt sich aber einer mit 100.000 Followern ein. So und alle so stehen plötzlich stramm und überlegen, der nächste Tweet muss mal genau sitzen. Also aber das Feld wird gar nicht, es wird nur genannt, so unter so einer Figur des dritten, wo ich mir denke, naja, aber wenn der große andere in weniger als nichts von Ciszek in einem tausendseitigen Buch oder so schon auf Seite zwei genannt wird, nachdem die Dummheit klassifiziert ist auf Seite eins, sage ich mir, diese Art von ganz klarer Philosophie, also inspiratives Denken, den man so ein bisschen, okay, finde ich unterhaltsam, das mal systematisch dem Phänomen nachzugehen, das uns nun wirklich prägt in dieser massenmedialen politischen Welt, in der es ganz, ganz, ganz viel drauf ankommt, wie eine Performance wohl von Dritten beobachtet wird. Ich meine, in der Auseinandersetzung Amerikas war völlig klar, ungefähr 70 Millionen wählen so und ungefähr 70 Millionen wählen so. Und es ging um diese eine Million Wechselwähler, Swing Votes ist noch nicht entschieden und so weiter. Nur darum ging es.
Deswegen gibt es diese Pennsylvania.
Genau. Wer macht für wen welches Theater, wer erklärt welche Verlierer, Opferschichten, Täter, wer macht welche Zurechnung. Nur darum geht es die ganze Zeit. Man kommt zum Buch und handelt es auf einer Seite so ab, ohne sich da mal einzumischen. Das ist eigentlich wirklich schade. Aber das Buch hat dann da diesen Bruch. Es geht in Teil zwei über Verlustpraxen der Moderne oder Verlustparadoxien der Moderne. Und uns wird nochmal erklärt, bisher gab es die christliche Religion, die auch eine tröstliche Kosmologie angeboten hat. Heute müssen in der Moderne Verluste anders verarbeitet werden. Okay, das Buch war gerade so spannend. Ja, und jetzt ist es wieder. Ja, es hat dann gerade so eingeladen, okay gut.
Und dann geht er da nochmal durch, wie er da kennt. Und dann konservative Verlustpolitik gibt es natürlich auch. Die wird dann erläutert. Da gibt es auch wieder verschiedene Formen. Wer hätte das gedacht? Also jene, die sich gegen liberale Elemente wenden, zum Beispiel Edmund Burke. Also wir sind jetzt im 19. Jahrhundert. Oder dann gibt es natürlich auch den konservativen Anspruch, dass man durchaus mit der Zeit gehen muss, damit sich am Ende grundsätzlich nichts verändert. Also das, zitiert er dann auch, ist zurückzuführen auf den Roman, der allerdings aus dem 20. Jahrhundert ist, aber im 19. Jahrhundert spielt. Der Leopard von Giuseppe Tomasi, Die Lampedusa. Manchmal muss man alles ändern, damit alles gleich bleibt. Ja, so in etwa paraphrasiert.
Du hast jetzt so einen Sing-Sang drin, den ich kurz aufgreifen möchte, weil der wirklich interessant ist. Denn es ist ja genau so. Er schreibt also, das Fortschritts-Narrativ hat kulturelle Metascripte, die er dann auch nur auffüllt mit Grundstimmung, Neugierde vor Freude, Begeisterung, genug Tugend, Zuversicht oder Trauer, Angst, Scham, Verbitterung, Wut, Empörung, Hass. Da denkt man sich so, ja, genau. Also du hast uns jetzt schon ganz oft abgeholt, dass die Soziologie Worte benutzt, wie die politische Welt. Nur jetzt geht auch mal diesen Schritt weiter. Stattdessen kommt eine Tabelle. Eine Tabelle, wo ich mich frage, bin ich jetzt hier in so einem Physikunterricht oder was? Wo einfach Tabellenspalte A, Fortschritts-Imperativ, Tabellenspalte B, Verlusterfahrung. Und er meinte, es sei wichtig, diese Tabelle jetzt zu explizieren. Nämlich Verbesserung, Verschlechterung, Lob der Zukunft, Lob der Vergangenheit, empathische Gegenwart, melancholische Gegenwart, Zukunft als Versprechen, Zukunft als Bedrohung, Narrativ des Erfolgs, tragisches Narrativ, Positivität der Emotionen, Negativität der Emotionen, Fülle, Mangel, Gestaltung, Aktivität, Leiden, Passivität, Unverfügbarkeit, Unendlichkeit, Berechenbarkeit, Unberechenbarkeit, sich befreiendes Subjekt, emotional gebundenes Subjekt, Freiheit und Überfluss, verletzliche Identität.
Ja, und dann könntest du noch weitermachen. Lachen, weinen, trocken, nass.
Also das kann man wirklich nur als Comedyprogramm wiedergeben. Es gibt keinen Modus, in dem man das ernsthaft in der Lesung vorlesen kann. Gibt's einfach nicht. Also gehört sowas nicht in den Texten.
Und derlei Auflistungen kommen dann noch weiter in den Fließtextformen, wenn er sagt, ja, um mit diesen Verlusten, die die Moderne mit sich bringt, umzugehen, neigt die Kultur dazu, eine ästhetische Melancholie auszuformulieren. Und dann zählt er einfach alles Mögliche auf. Er sagt dann, Michel Wabeck's Elementarteilchen, Franz Kafka's Der Verschollene, Orson Welles Citizen Kane. Und ja, ich könnte auch einfach feststellen, in der Literatur und im Film geht es meistens um Liebe und Tod. Oder um Liebe oder Tod.
Ja, genau. Also wir gehen hier einmal nur punktuell. Man kann das jetzt alles gar nicht so. Es ist Verlustpotenzierung. Also es gibt Verlustreduktion, Verlustpotenzierung, Verlustverschiebung, Verlust irgendwas. Ich nenne jetzt nur Sachen, die ich wirklich...
Werden so Begriffe eigentlich nur reingeschrieben, damit das dann in den nächsten soziologischen Arbeiten zitiert wird? Man schreibt dann Verlustpotenzierung in Klammern Reckwitz, Verlusteskalation in Klammern Reckwitz. Und dann hat man so einen unglaublichen Count von Quotes.
Ich will es nicht zu scharf urteilen, aber es ist Soziologen SEO, Search Engine Optimizing, denn du möchtest, dass deine Substantive nach denen gesucht werden, nur ich sage, nein, die Leute suchen nicht mehr nach Substantiven. Man kann Claude nach Konzepten fragen, per Plexity listet ihr sie auf. So, man braucht diese Substantivkaskade eigentlich nicht mehr. Er nennt aber mal eins bei Verlustpotenzierung, das finde ich ganz interessant, also demografisch angeleitet, der Hysteresis-Effekt. Typischerweise sterben Menschen mit 30 Jahren. Wir haben schon mal diese Pointe von Precht gebracht, dass der Tintenfisch ziemlich klug ist, aber er lebt nur zwei Jahre. Er kann keine Kultur weitergeben. Wir geben Kultur weiter. Nur leben Menschen nicht nur 30 Jahre, sondern 100 Jahre. Das heißt, 70-Jährige und damit die größte Wählergruppe, aber das ist jetzt mein Beitrag, das steht im Text nicht drin, aber es wäre so interessant gewesen. Die 70-Jährigen, die die größte Wählergruppe sind und die 60-Jährigen, die die größten Medienkonsumenten sind, denen wird Programm gemacht, das auf Verlusterfahrungen rekurriert, die 20- bis 40-Jährige gar nicht haben. Das geschah nämlich alles vor deren Geburt. Thomas Gottschalk kommt zurück ins Fernsehen. 30-Jährige so, was, keine Ahnung. Stefan Raab macht eine, er war ja nur zehn Jahre weg. Ja, also das heißt, heute leben, also es studieren Leute, die den nicht im Fernsehen gesehen haben. So. Das wird aber alles ausgeblendet durch den Hysterisis-Effekt. Und das finde ich auch, also das sind diese, das sind doch diese soziologisch interessanten Sachen, wo man sich jetzt wünscht, dass es hier 30 Seiten darum geht. So, nichts da. Eine halbe Seite, dann ist das schon wieder vorbei. Denn wir müssen ja die Vermarktlichung des Sozialen, die Ökonomie sortiert offenbar Gewinner und Verlierer. Ja, denn wir haben Arbeitsgüter, Wohnungs- und Partnerschafts- und Bildungsmärkte, auf denen nun sich Misserfolge durchaus mal aufsummieren können, so dass wir nicht nur vom Verlieren, sondern plötzlich von Verlierern sprechen. Was das 20. Date hat auch nicht funktioniert, du bist offenbar ein Verlierer. Auch das so Phänomene. Warum wird das nicht mal explizit an echten Problemen, die du gerade beantwortest? Nein, es ist so dieser Nachschlagewerkscharakter, dass es einfach nur so kurz aufsummiert wird. Und so wie sich Verluste potenzieren, können sich natürlich auch Erwartungen, er sagt dann expandieren. Okay, schön und gut, so geht es dann durch.
Ja, also wenn man sich jetzt heute Abend unterhält, kann man ja mal fragen, wer denn gerade eine Erwartungsexpansion erlebt hat, also mehr vom Leben will, als er jetzt gerade hat. Das ist dann eine Erwartungsexpansion. Vorsicht, Obacht, da können die Verluste sehr schnell kommen.
Er macht hier, das möchte ich jetzt wohlwollend aufgreifen, dann eine sehr schöne und also klar, ich schreibe jetzt über Familie im Buch, deswegen wandert das natürlich direkt rein. Wir haben es schon beschrieben, mit dem Verlust geht immer auch ein bisschen das Selbst. Man verliert immer ein bisschen das Selbst. Und ich habe ja gesagt, das ist vor allem Eva Elous Denkangebot. Und klar, sie schreibt ja dann auch über andere Sachen. Sie hat auch jetzt gerade wieder ein Buch über die Gefühlichkeit der Moderne. Also sie expandiert ihre eigenen Konzepte. Aber sie kommen eben aus diesem gefühligen, liebe Familie, Intimsphäre, wie auch immer. Und er kommt jetzt hier mit Identitätsstiftung. Also was ist dieses Selbst? Über das eigene Selbst hinaus und kommt auf die Familie zu sprechen. Denn in dem Moment, wo wir Haus und Hof trennen und sagen, die Männer gehen jetzt zur Arbeit, ist klar, die werden auf Arbeit nur als Rolle gebraucht. Rollenfüller. Sie sind dann nicht als ganze Figur. Wenn sie krank sind, müssen sie zu Hause bleiben. Denn da kümmert man sich um den ganzen kranken Körper, aber nicht auf Arbeit. So, das heißt, zu Hause kann man andere Erwartungen ausbilden und ausleben, als auf Arbeit. In der Ökonomie oder in der Politik oder wo auch immer. Und dadurch fand eine so ein verschiebe Bahnhof von welche Erwartungen ans Leben kann ich eigentlich haben und stelle ich gerade legitime Ansprüche an die Politik? Oder sollte ich nicht einfach sagen, ne, wenn ich zu fett bin, um zur Bahn zu rennen, kann ich nicht einfach politisch erwarten, dass sie bitte alle fünf Minuten fährt, sondern vielleicht liegt es an mir. Und dieses Zuschreiben, vielleicht liegt es an dir. Vielleicht ist dein Selbstbild, vielleicht musst du deinen Verlust mal woanders verrechnen. Also in Familie wird besonders viel Verlust verrechnet. Und dann würde ich jetzt sagen, mit der großen Gefahr, dass wenn diese Rechnung nicht aufgeht, doch wieder die Überweisung zurück an die Politik stattfindet. Aber auch hier wieder ein Gedanke, der sich ganz automatisch ergibt, wenn man das Buch liest, dem nicht nachgegangen wird. Ich verstehe gar nicht, wie man das schreiben kann, ohne dann diese Assoziation, diese interessante Frage sich zu stellen, welche Ansprüche stellt man gerade eigentlich an die Politik, obwohl sie da nicht hingehören? Und dann im zweiten Schritt aber doch hingehören, weil wir nämlich die Familie aus dem Blick gelassen haben, wo dies eigentlich aufgefangen werden sollte. Nur wie soll eine Familie was auffangen, wenn sie sich die ganze Zeit nur ökonomische Fragestellungen stellt?
Das Buch suggeriert eine Ausführlichkeit. Und es sieht so aus, weil es 500 Seiten sind, aber diese Ausführlichkeit ist gar nicht da. Es ist nur ein Aufrufen. Ja, da kann ich einfach sagen, da sind alte Praktiken, sondern da sind auch noch alte Einstellungen, Produktionsweisen, Ideensysteme, Gefühlskulturen. Also es werden immer gleich lange Auflistungen gemacht und dann wieder Begriffe geprägt, Regime der Obsoleszenz, ja, die Moderne produziert Verluste und zugleich strebt die Moderne nach Schmerzfreiheit. Generell streben Menschen nach Schmerzfreiheit, aber die Moderne nochmal in ganz besonderen Maße.
Ja, es verliert sich dann, wenn es empirisch wird.
Man weiß dann immer so ein bisschen, was gemeint ist und denkt, ja genau, deswegen tracken wir unseren Schlaf oder machen dies und das, damit man irgendwas besser unter Kontrolle hat, damit da nicht ein Verlust erlitten wird. Und das ist immer alles so gefühlt richtig. Nur weiß ich das ja auch schon. Aber es ist dann auch die Frage, wird das für mich zum Problem? Muss ich mich damit so näher beschäftigen? Und da müsste man tatsächlich mal auf eine geopolitische Ebene, glaube ich, kommen. Deswegen habe ich das eben gesagt, dass der Westen da mal so gesetzt wird. Es wird schon erwähnt, dass es um den Westen hauptsächlich geht. Aber dass man es ja mal in Relation zu den anderen Teilen dieser Welt setzen könnte und dann fragen könnte, ob diese Vorstellung von Fortschritt und von Verbesserung nicht gerade da zum Problem wird, wo konkurrierende Systeme auftauchen, die sagen, auch wir bieten Selbstverwirklichung an, nur in einem gänzlichen anderen Rahmen. Und ein Rahmen, der uns dann erstmal nicht zusagt. Und das ist ja eine zeitliche Veränderung, die zu erleben ist und die mit Verlusten zusammenhängt. Und wir hatten ja damals, als wir über das Subkutane sprachen, das Richard David Precht stark gemacht hat, dass also Leute diese Art von Verlust empfinden. Sie können es nicht genauso artikulieren, aber irgendetwas scheint dazu zu sein. Und wenn man dann aber da konkret weitergehen würde, dann wäre das auch interessant, auch mit Blick auf den Klimawandel. Ja, was ist denn da eigentlich? Was wir als Apokalypse ausmalen, was aber für die anderen schon eine Realität laufend ist, weshalb sie es gar nicht als Apokalypse sehen. Ich hatte in Heidelberg im Kino so eine Präsentation dieses Films Wir werden alle sterben von Ben Knight. Und da interviewte er Amitav Ghosh, ein Schriftsteller aus Indien, der jetzt in den USA lebt. Und der sagte, na ja, diese apokalyptische Sprechweise und wie der Westen über den Klimawandel nachdenkt, ja, wir gehen ja die ganze Zeit schon mit dem um. So, das ist eine ganz andere Herangehensweise. Aber das müsste man dann da reinschreiben. Und ich finde ja auch gut, wenn hier in der Soziologie sich jemand sagt, Verlust hängt mit dem Zeitlichen zusammen. Also die Zeit als Faktor oder fast als Akteur. Aber auch das müsste dann wirklich einmal nachvollzogen werden in einer Analyse. Du warst ja sehr begeistert davon. Ich fand es so halb gut das Buch von Hecklund. Hecklund hat ja die Zeit, die Vergänglichkeit, so in den Mittelpunkt gerückt. Und da kommt man ja auch zu Verlusten sehr schnell, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, auch den Verlust des eigenen Lebens. Und da wird aber eine Philosophie entfaltet, die ich hier nicht finden kann.
Ja, also bei Hecklund hatten wir es mit einem krass redundanten Buch zu tun, das uns wirklich die Lust des Lesens ausgetrieben hat. Aber die zentralen Ideen waren ganz gut. Genau, wir haben bisher, finde ich, ich will es mal klassifizieren, ästhetische Kritik, wir hätten uns gerne ein interessanteres, besser geschriebenes, narrativ gestaltetes, in der Gegenwart verankertes Buch gewünscht. Und meine Kritik wird gleich umschlagen. Ich werde gleich handfest sagen, nein, so geht das nicht. Also, ich will nur noch kurz weiter dieses Doing Loss, um das dahin zu führen. Wir bekommen als, finde ich, letzte Aufklärung, bevor das Buch seinen Charakter ändert, nämlich uns so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, bratschlagend belehrend möchte. Nochmal ein Hinweis darauf, dass wir Doing Loss so verstehen sollen. Früher hatten wir christliche Seelsorge, heute haben wir Aftlichtversicherung, heute haben wir vorsorgende Politik, wie auch immer. Das schlägt sich so nieder in verschiedenen Kulturen. Wir haben so eine Art von Verlustpolitik, also sozusagen eine Rentenpolitik. Ihr verliert irgendwann eure Arbeit, das können wir aber konstruktiv gestalten. Wir haben eine Therapeutisierung. Er kommt dann nochmal auf die Nostalgie und das Risiko zu sprechen. Also die Nostalgie so als Popkultur, die durchaus auch mal beispielsweise beim Verlust der Heimat in der, wie heißt es nochmal, es ist nicht nur das Judentum, das auswandern musste, sondern die Deaspora. Also in der Deaspora kann die Erinnerung an die eigene Kultur besonders orthodoxe Züge annehmen. Es gibt da so Steigerungen von wie auch immer. Und dann eben, wir haben Risiko, also die Zurechnung auf eine eigene Entscheidung. Es ist nicht einfach eine kosmische Gefahr. Also können wir uns auch versichern und ein Risikomanagement machen und Reversibilitäten einführen, wie auch immer. So und dann kommt aber ein Textteil, das Buch auch, finde ich so, als darauf soll es hinauslaufen. Wo bist du jetzt, wenn ich dich zum Thema akzeptanz? Therapeutisierung von Verlusterfahrungen. Kann ich dir eine Seitenzahl nennen? Weiß ich gar nicht. Nee, habe ich nichts mir niedergeschrieben, aber...
Also irgendwie schon bei dem Doing-Lost-Kapitän.
Ja, ja, ja.
Doing-Lost, Doing-Lost, Doing-Lost.
Wir sind schon ziemlich weit hinten. Er spricht hier von einer Therapeutisierung. Wir können uns beim Verlust hyposensibilisieren, um ihn irgendwann zu akzeptieren. Und er sagt, und dazu gibt es ja Psychologie, Moral, Philosophie, was auch immer, idealerweise verschwindet am Ende der Therapie tatsächlich der Verlust. Und zwar nicht dadurch, dass das Verlustobjekt zurückkehrt oder der Verlust kompensiert wird, also jemand eine Entschädigungszahlung macht, sondern weil sich das Verlustobjekt selbst grundlegend wandelt. Das heißt, auch Christian Lindner, nicht nur Habeck und Scholz werden dieses Buch interessiert lesen, weil ja hier irgendwie, denkt man sich so, angedeutet wird, der Bürgergeldempfänger muss gar nicht so leiden. Wir können ihn auch einen Gedanken hinein therapieren, dass er ja hier in Deutschland Bürgergeldempfänger ist und nicht in Nigeria auf der Straße lebt. Also er kann einfach akzeptieren, statt dass wir ihm jetzt den Verlust des Einkommens durch Ausrätieren von was auch immer, welcher Industrie, entschädigen oder da Ersetzungen stattfinden lassen, sondern es liegt im Subjekt selbst. Und das finde ich, wenn Verlust vorher ein bisschen in der Schwebe gelassen wird, kreuz und quer verankert, aber nicht verortet wird. Wenn das Fundament nicht steht, kann man so nicht argumentieren.
Ich kann dir hier meine Notizen zeigen. Wir kommen hier bei derselben Sache raus.
Also das finde ich nicht gut. Und das Buch macht ab hier keine Wände, man wackelt nur mehr davon.
Wir haben eben, hatte ich gemeint, ich finde das schwierig, wenn man anthropologische Konstanten und Verlusterfahrungen, die einfach im menschlichen Leben liegen, vermischt mit Verlusterfahrungen, die gesellschaftlich gemacht sind oder politisch gewollt sind. Und da führt es eigentlich dann nämlich hin, wenn ich sage, ein jeder Mensch wird in seinem Leben Verluste erleiden, Verwandte werden sterben, damit muss man umgehen und damit muss man auch selbst fertig werden. Wenn ich aber jetzt sage, ja werde doch damit innerlich fertig, wenn du aus deiner Wohnung rausgeschmissen wirst, dann ist das was fundamental anderes, denn das, was es gesellschaftlich macht, das heißt, es ist veränderbar. Den Tod von Mitmenschen kann ich nicht stoppen, das kann ich nicht beenden, aber ich kann das andere schon beenden.
Ich sage mal so, das Verlustthema hier am Ende, wäre ihm, also er hätte sich das gar nicht getraut, uns den Täter auszureden, wenn er ihn vorher ordentlich benannt hätte. Nur das macht er nicht.
Er spricht nämlich dann über den Populismus und sagt, im populistischen Narrativ werden eindeutige Schuldige für die Beklagten oder zu erwartenden Verluste dingfest gemacht. Gegen sie richtet sich dessen Zornpolitik. Weder also scheinen die Individuen selbst für ihre Verluste verantwortlich, noch werden diese als Ergebnis ungeplante anonymer Prozesse gedeutet. Es gibt vielmehr vermeintlich Verantwortliche und Ratsier. Es gibt in Anführungszeichen Täter, die meistens auch als Profiteure der Verluste der anderen interpretiert werden. Beispielsweise globale oder nationale Eliten, feministische Frauen, Migranten. Gut, schön. Wir wissen, wie manche populistischen Strömungen irgendwelche Täter ausmachen, die überhaupt nichts dafür können. Zum Beispiel Trump macht den Feminismus dafür verantwortlich, für irgendetwas. Wir müssen aber sagen, dass wir nicht bei Täter grundsätzlich Anführungszeichen setzen können. Wir können nicht sagen, dass es vermeintliche Verantwortliche gibt, sondern wie wir dank Julia Friedrichs, dank Philippa Siegel-Klöckner gesehen haben, gibt es Verantwortliche, die für etwas gesorgt haben. Und es ist dann nicht nur Ressentiment oder vermeintliche Wahrnehmung, sondern es ist Realität und zwar ökonomische Realität. Und hinter der stecken auch Leute, die das entscheiden. Und sei es ein Seehofer, der sich bequatschen lässt und sagt, ja, dann sollen die mal die Betriebsvermögen mal so parken, dass das nicht besteuert wird. Und da sind Verantwortliche und da kann man nicht sagen, ja, das muss dann in einem selbst irgendwie liegen, damit fertig zu werden. Nein, es sind nicht private Schicksalsschläge hier, sondern es sind gesellschaftlich gemachte Zustände.
Wir können das ja direkt. Wir haben ja Hörer, die auch den letzten Salon gehört haben, also das Seehofer-Narrativ, die Geschichtsschreibung zu Seehofer. Und die stellen wir jetzt mal gegenüber zu dem, was hier im Buch steht. Beklage dich nicht über Seehofer, sondern verstehe, dass es eine Urszene des Verlusts gibt, deine Geburt. Du wirst in die Welt geworfen und der Akt ist ein Verlust. Du verlierst die dich in allen Belangen ausstattende Mutter und musst jetzt bald selber klarkommen. Die ganze Sozialisation, Integration in die Gesellschaft ist das Abarbeiten an einer Verlusterfahrung. Zweitens, auch psychologisch, Trennungen. Die persönliche Trennung von sich liebenden Menschen kann für den Verlassenen, er sagt schon, es gibt nicht richtig Täter, so beide verlassen sich einander, also es gibt so zwei Zurückgelassene. Das kann man durchaus als neutralen psychologischen Begriff sehen, denn es ist ja nicht zwingend, dass diese Trennung Verlust enthalten muss, wenn plötzlich Räume da sind, sich umso mehr in dieser Welt wiederzufinden. Und jetzt gibt es, finde ich, sollte man darauf hinweisen, einen großen Unterschied, ob man eine Konzeption für die Beobachtung von sozialer Gegenwart anbietet oder Illustrationen für einen Begriff. Und es ist nicht dasselbe. Philippa Siegel-Klöckner hat uns ein Konzept zur Beobachtung unserer Gegenwart angeboten und sie hat sich einen historischen Punkt ausgesucht, der ist immens wichtig für uns. Da fand eine Entscheidung statt von jemandem, die unerklärlich damals war und heute umso wirkmächtiger ist, weil sie so unerklärlich ist.
Und es wäre völlig obskur, wenn Philippa Siegel-Klöckner nun schreiben würde, Schuld. Wir alle werden manchmal schuldig.
Ja, das würde wirklich auffallen in dem Text.
Wir verschulden uns beieinander, wir fühlen Schuld, wir haben alle mit Schuld, auch in den Beziehungen, auch in den Leuten, die wir lieben. Nee, es geht jetzt hier um die Schuldenbremse.
Genau, es geht um die Schuldenbremse. Es geht ums Geld. Es geht um eindeutige Kennziffern auf einem Blatt Papier. Das wird verrechnet. Da kann man mit solchen Konzeptziffern, also Illustrationen von Begriffen, nicht kommen. Die Verlusteskalation in der Spätmoderne. Wir nähern uns hier den Punkten, die ich nicht gut finde.
Als hättest du die anderen schon gut gefunden.
Aber jetzt wird es sozusagen politisch relevant. Und ich will erinnern, hört euch diesen Podcast bei Surkamp an. Er verortet die Soziologie als Dienstleistung für die Gesellschaft, genau wie ich auch. Ja, Theorierarbeit ist auch nötig, aber dafür gibt es heilige Räume. Man nennt sie Elfenbeintürme, wie auch immer, Universitäten. Da kann es manchmal gelingen, aber nicht in dieser Art Bücher. Die richten sich an ein Publikum. Und er beschreibt hier unter Verlusteskalation in der Spätmoderne dieses Phänomen. Wir wissen, dass wir auf der einen Seite die Erodierung eines Fortschritts-Narrativen haben, das diesen Verlustglauben nach sich zieht. Also gesamtgesellschaftlich wird jetzt immer mehr Verluste den Gewinnen, den Fortschritten gegenübergestellt. Wir machen also eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Verlusterfahrung, während gleichzeitig die Subjektivierung des Fortschritts floriert. Und das ist ein ganz großes Paradox. Die Leute werden gefragt, wie geht es der Gesellschaft? Und sie sagen, super scheiße, ich habe Angst um die Zukunft, wie auch immer. Wie geht es ihnen selber? Bestes Jahr ever. Drei Urlauber gemacht, geheiratet, was auch immer. Das fällt also auseinander. Und hier markiert er einen Verlust, von dem ich sage, das ist der wichtigste Verlust überhaupt, aber da er sich keine Namen und keine Empirie zutraut, benennt er ihn nicht. Und deshalb sage ich jetzt nicht nur nochmal, dass es demnächst von Aleida und Jan Aßmann ein Buch über Gemeinsinn gibt, denn er nennt ja beide auch. Sie spielen ja so in Erinnerung, Wissen, Gedächtnis und so weiter große Rolle. Sondern bei ihm ist diese Art von Verlust des Gemeinsinns, also Klammer zwischen Subjekt und Gesellschaft, das was verloren geht. Der Klappentext lautet in diesem Buch wie folgt, also jetzt im Gemeinsinnsbuch von den Aßmanns. Die resiliente Demokratie braucht kein Feindbild, aber einen starken Sinn für das, was Menschen miteinander verbindet und zusammenhält. Dass Menschen mitfühlend und solidarisch sein können, bestätigen uns inzwischen die Neurowissenschaften. Dieser sechste soziale Sinn braucht allerdings auch die Stütze einer entsprechenden politischen Kultur. So, wenn wir uns in Autokratien unter, also verwandeln, dann heißt es nur, wir akzeptieren das politische Narrativ, das uns angeboten wird, dass wir uns gegen einen äußeren Feind wehren müssen. Die Migranten überfluten uns, wir müssen gegen China richtige Geschütze auffahren und so weiter und so fort. Dann brauchen wir keinen Gemeinsinn. Dann kehrt einfach jeder vor seine eigenen Tür und aufsummiert ergibt das dann, der andere ist schuld. So, ich habe mein Haus in Ordnung. Die Demokratie dagegen kann sich nur über einen Blick nach innen stabilisieren. Und der geht gerade verloren. Und wenn jetzt Andreas Reckwitz einfach sagt, aber ich als Soziologe, soziale Phänomene, ich erkläre das mit der Geburt, mit der Trennung im bewahrten Raum und so, dann ist man da auf der falschen Spur. Man ist auf dem falschen Feld. Hier macht das Buch selber eine Verlustanerkennung über Verschweigen eines sozialen Phänomens, dass wir als das Eigentliche was verloren gegangen ist, nämlich einen Gemeinsinn, Jenseits, Familie und wo ich zur Arbeit gehe. Diese dritten Orte wird das dann immer genannt. Mal am Nahverkehr teilnehmen, statt einfach nur festzustellen, das ist echt scheiße, dass die Bahn so unpünktlich ist, aber mein Porsche fährt echt geil. Dazwischen ist noch was, nur das wird immer weiter ausgeblendet. Jetzt haben wir Christian Lindner schon verabschiedet, also wir könnten uns jetzt wieder einblenden, mal gucken, wie sich die CDU so verhält. Also dieses Gemeinsinnbuch scheint mir ein Gegenmittel zu sein, gegen so eine Verlusterklärung, Deklaration, die uns hier einfach gegeben wird. Das ist aber nicht die eigentliche Kritik, sondern ich möchte auf ganz spezifische Textstellen zu sprechen kommen, die am Ende gemacht werden, in dem Begriffe falsch verwendet werden, denn der Verlust, dieses Buch findet 2024 statt, weil es geht so nicht mehr weiter. Wir verlieren zu viel. Die Verlusterfahrungen sind zu groß. Der Begriff, der diese Steigerung fasst, lautet Erschöpfung. Ja, wir sind erschöpft.
Und jetzt schreibt er, Erschöpfungsverlust nennt er es. Genau.
Und ich will es mal vorlesen. In der spätmoderne bildet sich schließlich eine besondere Form des Verlusts heraus, die Erschöpfungsverluste. Es handelt sich um Verluste, die anzeigen, dass die westliche Moderne in Sachen Dynamik und Expansivität an ihre Grenzen stößt, sich erschöpft. Diese Erschöpfung, und ich betone die Erschöpfung, soweit ich die gleich austausche gegen einen anderen Begriff. Diese Erschöpfung betrifft drei elementare Bereiche. Jetzt wird es super interessant, denn das ist im Grunde das, was auf meinem Buchdeckel stehen wird. Also drei elementare Bereiche, welche die Fortschrittsorientierung dieser Gesellschaftsform in den vergangenen 250 Jahren als gegebenes, als passives, stummes Objekt der Optimierung und Ausbeutung voraussetzen konnte. Erstens, die Erde. Damit ist gemeint, die Zukunft, das Klima und so weiter, die Welt ist erschöpft, wenn dieser Verbrauchstag da im April ist und wir eigentlich vier Erden bräuchten für die Deutschen. Das geht das einfach nicht. Zweitens, der menschliche Körper. Da würde ich sagen, ja, genau, Familie. Die Familie ist erschöpft.
Er meint, dass ja vor allem der Körper auch dann nicht mehr mitmacht, also der zu gebrechlich ist.
Wir können zu Hause nicht mehr regenerieren oder wie auch immer. Drittens, die globale Welt. Und ich erinnere daran, Gerd Müller ging als Entwicklungshilfeminister aus dem Amt und sagte, es ist unglaublich, aber für jeden von uns arbeiten auf der Welt 50 Sklaven. Ich bekomme häufiger die Frage, wurde das geschrieben oder gesagt? Also er hat es gesagt in der Präsentation des Lieferkettengesetzes und er hat es geschrieben in seinem Buch, dass er zur Amtszeit noch veröffentlicht hat. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, der beruft sich aber auf so eine Studie aus Düsseldorf, die nicht sehr tragfähig ist, dann sage ich, ja, dann nehmen halt fünf Sklaven. Wenn du glaubst, dadurch ist das Problem kleiner, ist jetzt, weiß nicht, was geworden ist. So, und jetzt schreibt er. Und dieser Satz, den dreh ich ihm jetzt einfach sozusagen um. In der Spätmoderne ist ein Punkt erreicht, in dem alle drei Sphären sich einer weiteren Ausschöpfung und Optimierung entziehen. Dadurch ergibt sich Instabilitäten und Verletzlichkeiten neuer Art. Akzeptiere ich nicht, das so zu schreiben. Denn der Satz lautet wie folgt richtig. In der Spätmoderne ist ein Punkt erreicht, in dem alle drei Sphären sich einer weiteren Ausbeutung entziehen. Dieses Buch zum Thema Verlust wäre, akkurat formuliert, eine Geschichte der Ausbeutung. Und diese Ausbeutung kommt jetzt an Grenzen. Es ist eine Ausbeutungserschöpfung. Wir können nicht weiter ausbeuten. Wir kommen planetare, zeitliche und vor allem psychologische Grenzen der Ausbeutung. Und dass hier nicht Ausbeutung, sondern Ausschöpfung steht, kann ich nicht tolerieren.
Ja und ich habe eine Ahnung, warum das so ist, damit man nicht in zu politisches Fahrwasser gerät, damit man so everybody's darling bleiben kann. Und das ist ja auch ein Wort.
Er wendet sich ja am Anfang gegen die unnötige Dramatisierung. Ich würde sagen, unnötige Dramatisierung. Donald Trump wurde gewählt. Donald Trump wurde schon mal gewählt. Es kann passieren, es wird wieder passieren. Diesen Text, den ich nachher vorstelle, der behandelt einfach die Frage, was ist, wenn nach zehn Jahren Remigration in Amerika nicht funktioniert und trotzdem das Problem gelöst werden muss? Und wir wissen, es wurde schon mal eine Endlösung formuliert. Und diese Texte werden uns heute empfohlen auf Nachfrage, liebes Auswärtiger Amt, wie behandelt ihr jetzt intern diesen Sieg von Donald Trump? Und dann kommt als Antwort, wir lesen solche Texte, in denen das formuliert wird. Also es ist wirklich super brenzlig eigentlich. Hier jetzt so ein beschwichtigendes, ja, der Verlust ist echt blöd jetzt, also wir müssen jetzt mal uns in Akzeptanz üben. Das geht einfach nicht. Also es ist einfach keine adäquate, auf Augenhöhe mit dem Moment Soziologie, die man empfehlen kann.
Und es geht auch nicht, dass man dann einfach auf den drei letzten Seiten auch mal sagt, naja, vielleicht gibt es irgendwo anders eine Renaissance der Moderne und dann nicht hier. Dann müsste man die westliche Perspektive vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen früher hinterfragen. Auch, dass man dann mal sagt, es könnte noch eine radikalere Version der Moderne geben. Die KI, das wird dann auch noch mal kurz aufgerufen. Ja, wie sähe die dann aus? Und dann geht er dazu über, dass er sagt, aber man könnte auch was reparieren. Auch da hätte ich gerne konkret was erfahren. Was meint denn Reparatur? Also nur in mir selbst oder gesellschaftliche Reparatur. Und wir wissen gerade, wie viel Porzellan zerschlagen wurde oder wie viel Elend produziert wurde, dadurch, dass man diese Austeritätspolitik hier in Deutschland hat. Wir haben gesehen, dass diese ganze Polarisierung, die stattgefunden hat, das Entweder-oder, von dem der Kanzler jetzt in seiner Ansprache dort sprach, dass das AfD und Co. so stark gemacht hat. Wir wissen, dass dieses Entweder-oder ein großes Problem ist. Wir haben aber eine Möglichkeit, einen Kuchen zu vergrößern. Man macht es nicht. Dann müsste man darüber reden als Reparatur der Moderne. Und dann aber wirklich ganz am Ende noch mal einen Bezug zu Sigmund Freud herzustellen und zu sagen, es geht ja auch um so etwas wie Akzeptanz von Verlust.
Ein augenöffnender Gedanke, sagt er.
Ja, dann bin ich an einem Punkt angelangt, wo ich eigentlich hier Status-Quo-Bestätigung nach 500 Seiten betreibe.
Ich will es drastischer formulieren, indem ich vorlese, was er schreibt. Also wir sind auf Seite 418 von 425, vorher ewig lang Literatur-Teil. Er hat viel geschrieben, er hat viel gelesen, wir sind genau dazwischen, wir wollen jetzt wissen, was ist hier los. Und er schreibt zum Thema und er schlägt erst dann diese Reparatur vor. Reparatur verweist vielmehr auf eine Haltung, in der man zunächst mit den gegebenen Institutionen und Lebensformen arbeitet, aber sie so ausbessert, dass sie sich gleichermaßen nüchtern und offensiv der Problematik von Verletzlichkeit und Verlust stellen, statt vor dieser die Augen zu verschließen. Nach der Reparatur strahlt die reparierte Moderne nicht im Glanz des kompletten Neuen, sie enthält vielmehr die Spuren, Vergangene, Defekte, Verserungen und Verschleißerscheinungen. Das ist nicht mal mehr deklarativ, das ist appellativ. Das ist ein rein politischer Satz. Und noch schlimmer ist sein finaler Gedanke. Das, was ich jetzt vorlese, steht so im Buch. Sich den Verlust Geschichten zu stellen, anstatt sich in endloser Täter, Opfer oder Gewinner-Verlierer-Dynamik zu verirren, wäre ein unverzichtbarer Bestandteil einer selbst effektiv gewordenen Moderne. Und ich sage nein, nicht nur sage ich nein, sondern das Gegenteil ist wahr. Ich lehne das ab. Die Kämpfe, die zu führen sind, sind zu führen. Jetzt einfach die Verlierer und Opfer mit Erklärung ruhig zu halten und dann die Verserrungen und Verschleißungen ins Museum zu stellen.
Wir brauchen nur mal ein paar Narrative und dann wird das schon wieder allen gut gehen. Und es ist wirklich, wo du das eben schon mal sagtest mit Christian Lin, ist das wirklich so was, was man ja in den Lindner-Reden finden kann, wenn dann jemand sagt, wieso halten sie noch immer am Dieselprivileg fest? Dann sagt er, also wenn ich schon das Wort Privileg genöre, da wird immer so getan, als ginge es den einen besser und den anderen schlechter. Und wir würden sagen, ja doch, genau so ist es ja. Aber Lindner sagt dann, nein, so dürfen wir doch gar nicht darüber nachdenken. Und wenn jetzt so getan wird, dass ich derjenige bin, der die Interessen einer kleinen Klientel vertritt, so wird immer getan. Und da denkt man, ja, genau so bist du ja auch. Und hier werden wir eigentlich auch dazu aufgefordert, nicht mehr in Gegensätzen, nicht mehr in Klassengegensätzen, nicht mehr in Form von Verlierern und Gewinnern. Aber ganz klar, ich rufe den MSCI World und die Realdohnentwicklung ins Gedächtnis. Gibt es ja Gewinner und Verlierer und die sind nicht einfach so entstanden. Ich bin da wirklich ratlos, wie man das angesichts der Lage, in der wir uns befinden, schreiben kann. Insofern war das aber jetzt erhellend, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Wir haben, glaube ich, viel Klarheit über so eine intellektuelle Produktion von Status Quo-Bestätigung gesprochen.
Absolut.
Miley de Kerangal ist eine französische Schriftstellerin, die jetzt bei Surkamp einen ganz schmalen Roman herausgebracht hat, der aber sehr gewichtig ist. Er trägt den Titel Weiter nach Osten. Dieser Roman ist lange bevor Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine begann, geschrieben wurden. Zum Glück, also es gibt da nicht irgendwelche Bezüge direkt politisch, aber es ist selbstredend ein politischer Roman. Und es ist ein Roman, der aber jetzt nicht uns zeigt, wie finster Russland ist, sondern er zeigt uns eigentlich, was es bedeutet, wenn Männer in den Krieg ziehen müssen bzw. erst einmal eingezogen werden, um sich dann diesem Grundwehrdienst auszusetzen. Und wenn man eigentlich doch für sein Leben etwas anderes sich gedacht hat, wenn man eigentlich nicht Kanonenfutter werden will, wenn man nicht mit all diesen anderen komischen Männern zusammen sein will, eng gedrängt dort jetzt in der Zukunft, in der Kantine sitzen muss, auf der Stube sitzen muss, wenn man tatsächlich anders leben wollte und einem diese Freiheit genommen wird, davon handelt dieser Roman und von der Solidarität, die dann entstehen kann. Im Mittelpunkt steht Aljosha, ein junger Mann, der jetzt auch in diese transsibirische Eisenbahn muss, die ihn weit, weit, weit fortbringt von zu Hause. Dort soll er seinen Grundwehrdienst ableisten. Er weiß nicht, wie ihm geschieht. Er sieht schon die anderen Kerle dort um ihn herum, wie sie zum Teil verroht sind oder verroht sein werden in Zukunft, wie die Männlichkeitsrituale, die in der Stube auf ihn warten, ihn wahrscheinlich zerstören werden. Und er ist aber so, dass er sich in diesem Zug ein bisschen fortbewegt und dort zufällig auf eine Französin trifft. Sie ist mit einem Russen zusammen, von dem sie sich aber eigentlich getrennt hat und jetzt doch wohl wieder zurück will. Diese Französin beginnt ein Gespräch mit ihm, obwohl sie gar nicht miteinander kommunizieren können. Aber sie rauchen miteinander. Sie kommen sich in irgendeiner Weise nahe. Aber es ist keine sexuelle Erzählung jetzt hier. Es ist jetzt nicht die heiße Affäre in der transsibirischen Eisenbahn. Aber es passiert etwas Zwischenmenschliches zwischen ihnen, dass für Aljosha die Rettung sein könnte. Und das Besondere hier ist, dass wir es mit einem sprachlich wirklich sehr ausgefeilten Roman zu tun haben, auf höchstem literarischen Niveau. Und was eher selten ist, ist, dass wir es zugleich mit einem unheimlich spannenden Text zu tun haben. Hier kommt es auf die Sekunde an, wird er doch entdeckt, dieser Aljosha, der dann in die erste Klasse aufbricht irgendwann, um dort sich gemeinsam mit der Französin vor seinen Kameraden und davor seinen Vorgesetzten zu verstecken. Der Roman beginnt zunächst einmal so. Die da kommen aus Moskau und wissen nicht, wohin sie fahren. Es sind viele, über hundert, junge Kerle, blass, geradezu bleich, abgezerrt und kahl geschoren, die Arme senig, der Blick starr, der Oberkörper in ein kaki-farbnes Unterhemd gezwenkt, Tarnhosen und Slips mit Eingriff, das fromme Kettchen baumelt auf der Brust, Wände aus Kerlen in den Gängen, Sitzende, Stehende, auf den Pritschen liegende Kerlen, die ihren Arm, ihre Füße, ihre resignierte Langeweile ins Leere hängen lassen. Über 40 Stunden sind sie schon hier, dicht an dicht, eingegeilt in der Latenzzeit des Zugs, rekruten. So rhythmisch, wie ein Zug rattert, beginnt also dieser Text. Und dann lernen wir gleich auf Seite 3 Aljosha kennen. Bis zuletzt hat Aljosha geglaubt, er werde nicht fahren. Bis zum 1. April, dem Tag der traditionellen Frühjahrseinberufung, hat er gedacht, er könne dem Militärdienst entgehen, das System austricksen und sich freistellen lassen. Und übrigens gibt es in Moskau keinen einzigen, zwischen 18 und 27, der nicht dasselbe versucht. Bei diesem Spiel sind die Söhne aus guter Familie im Vorteil. Die anderen lavieren sich durch, während ihre Mütter sich auf dem Pushkinplatz die Kehle aus dem Leib schreien. In größerer Zahl seit dem Martyrium des Soldaten Südschow und versammelt um Valentina Melnikova, die Vorsitzende des Komitees der Soldatenmütter. Beeindruckend, wütend, resolut. Und wenn die Kameras auftauchen, strecken sie ihnen die entschlossenen Gesichter entgegen. Ich will nicht, dass meiner dahin geht. Außerdem trinkt er nicht. Denn der Alkoholismus ist natürlich dort auch ein großes Thema. Und so wird diese Fahrt geschildert. Es wird die russische Landschaft, diese unheimlich weite Landschaft geschildert. Die man sehen kann, wenn man aus dem Fenster blickt. Es ist ein Text, der diese Natur auch ein genießen lässt. Und zugleich das Unerbittliche zeigt dieses Landes, nämlich dass das Individuum dort auch nichts ist. Dass wenn immer der Staat, das Militär ruft, das Individuum nichts ist. Und dann gibt es aber das, was zwischen Menschen passieren kann. Und da heißt es dann, einige Seiten später, als er die Französin Elain kennenlernt. Er, also Aljosha, will mit ihr kommen, in ihr Abteil, will nicht zurückkehren in die Wagen der dritten Klasse zu Letschow, dem Sadisten und den anderen kahlgeschorenen im Drillich. Er will, dass sie ihn versteckt. Verstehst du? Verstehst du? Er hält sie an den Schultern und schüttelt sie wie einen Pflaumenbaum, zieht schließlich seine Militärpapiere aus der Gesäßtasche seiner Hose und tut, als würde sie zerreißen, schleudert seine Plastikkarte auf den Boden und trampelt darauf herum, wirft zwischendurch unruhige Plicke zu Elen, die verstanden zu haben, glaube ich. Du willst da nicht hin, richtig? Ich muss dazu sagen, es wird alles in einem Fließtext hier geschrieben, aber es gibt nicht die Dialoge mit Anführungszeichen. Die Landschaft zieht jetzt vor den Fenstern der grauen Zelle vorbei, die sie zusammen besetzt haben, wo sie eng beieinander, vereint im selben Gerüttel, derselben Beschleunigung, derselben Verlangsamung den Rauch ihrer Kippen und die Wärme ihres Atems vermengt haben. Aljosha hält die Luft an. Er fleht nicht. Er ist kein Opfer. Er ist wie sie. Er läuft davon. Das ist alles. Die Frau schaut dem Jungen in die Augen. Eine Lichtung öffnet sich im schmutzigen Morgengrauen, sehr grün, beißt sich auf die Lippen. Folge mir. Und den Rest muss dann jeder selber lesen.
Wie lange dauert diese Zugfahrt? Das ist sehr lang, weil das Buch ist so kurz.
Die Zugfahrt dauert viele, viele Stunden und ein Morgen. Und es wird nicht einfach sein. Und es gibt noch eine dritte Figur, von der, verrate ich aber jetzt nicht, von dieser dritten Figur erfahren wir auch nichts Persönliches. Denn hier findet schon eine persönliche Geschichte statt. Und man kann sich vorstellen, da helfen zwei einander. Wenn man jemanden näher kennenlernt, dann hilft man. Aber das Interessante ist, dass es noch eine dritte Figur gibt, von der wir nichts erfahren und von deren Motiven wir auch nichts erfahren. Und die ist aber auch zu etwas bereit.
Okay, ein bewegendes Kammerspiel. Der Zukunftsplan von McKinsey, Boston Consulting und Roland Berger. Ich ziehe also einen Text vor und wir machen uns nicht über ihn lustig, sondern wir lesen jetzt die Regierungsagenda der nächsten zwei Wochen, wenn wir nicht von einer Regierung, sondern von einem Konvent oder so regiert werden. Also Tanja Kevis hat die Berichterstattung dazu gemacht im Handelsblatt. Die Deutschlandchefs Fabian Billing, Michael Briegel, Stefan Scheible haben ein ganz besonderes Vorhaben, das jeder der drei erfahrenen Berater herausgefordert hat. Nicht nur intellektuell, sondern auch emotional. Ich bleibe mal im Doktors, ich mache eigentlich lustig drüber, aber durch die Realität wurden wir eingeholt. Die drei hierzulande führenden Managementberatungen haben für das Handelsblatt, da stehe ich nicht so ganz, warum jetzt für das Handelsblatt, in wochenlanger Arbeit eine gemeinsame Strategie für Deutschland entwickelt. 93 Seiten, Agenda 2035 in Anlehnung an die Agendas, die wir schon hatten. Also Agenda 2010. In Summe neuer Wachstumspfad, ohne dabei ökologische oder soziale Aspekte zu vernachlässigen. Chancen werden natürlich hier genutzt. Die Krisen sollen ja nicht verschwindet werden. Es geht um unsere Ingenieurskompetenz, Spitzenforschung und Technologieführerschaft. Also der Staat soll bitte Rahmenbedingungen schaffen. Die Menschen mögen bitte den Schulterschluss üben. Die Lage ist ernst. Es geht um nicht weniger als um die Sicherung von Wohlstand und Demokratie, sagt Priegel, also Europaschef der BCG. Für uns als Berater war es daher eine moralische Verpflichtung und ein Ansporn zugleich, uns mit einem Wurf einzubringen, wie die deutsche Wirtschaft sich wieder in der Weltspitze etablieren kann. Diesen Satz nehmen wir jetzt ernst. Das Erfolgsrezept der Bundesrepublik war seit jeher eine florierende Wirtschaft, dank der ein guter, ausgebauter Sozialstaat finanziert werden konnte. Ich würde jetzt sagen, nein, das Henne-Ei-Problem ist gelöst. Man musste zuerst den Leuten sagen, eure Kinder gehen ab jetzt in die Schule. Danach kam die Wirtschaft. Also nicht nur das Wirtschaftswachstum, sondern überhaupt die Wirtschaft. Man kann nicht sagen, die Wirtschaft muss erst mal und dann können wir Spreiräume benutzen für ein besseres Leben zu Hause. Nein, ihr wollt ausgeschlafene, gesunde Leute auf Arbeit haben. Gerade jetzt, wo so viel von ihnen verlangt ist. Andersrum, das ist auch kein Gedöns oder Gefühlichkeit, sondern es ist ein ganz einfach zu verstehener, funktionaler Zusammenhang. Wenn man den nicht akzeptiert, geht's schief. Gut, aber so weit. Wir haben jedenfalls eine Schieflage, die muss nun ausgebessert werden. Die Zielparameter sind Wirtschaftswachstum pro Einwohner und Exportquote. Und ich kommentiere, oh je. Deutschland ist ein Restrukturierungsfall, sagt der Scheibler von Roland Berger. Alle Akteure von Unternehmen, Arbeitnehmern, Wissenschaftlern, Entscheidungsträgern und engagierte Bürger müssten in einen konstruktiven Dialog treten und sich auf die notwendigen Veränderungen einlassen. Hier will uns wieder jemand Veränderungen sagen und Verlust meinen. Ja, aber gut.
Und notwendig, weil kein Weg dran vorbeigeht.
Ja, das ist alternativlos. Die Maßnahmen sind Produktivität erhöhen, Lieferketten absichern. Deutschlands Kernindustrie ist zu 20 Prozent in der Substanz gefährdet. Wir brauchen also einen Dreiklang aus Investition, Innovation, Effizienz. Okay, Schuldenbremse muss reformiert werden. Später dann nochmal ein extra Abschnitt dazu. Mehr privates Wagniskapital, also vor allem mehr Spielräume, wo man finanziell, also finanziell sich einbringen darf, obwohl man eigentlich seinen Nutzern, wie Pensionären, Versprechen der Stabilität macht. Also da sieht man schon, okay, das geht vielleicht in die falsche Richtung. Außerdem mehr eigene Rohstoffe nutzen, um weniger von Lieferketten abhängig zu sein.
Fracking.
Ja, also das ist dieses Trumpsche Grenzen hoch. Und schaut euch mal unsere Assets an. Wir haben ganze Gebirgsketten, in denen findet noch nichts statt. Also da mal gucken. Digitalisierung, Mobilität, Klimatechnologie, Pharma. Sie nennen 50 Technologien, die bald in zehn Jahren mehr als 15 Milliarden Umsatz machen. Billionen Umsatz machen. Da soll sich Deutschland gezielt darauf einbringen. Da würde ich sagen, ah ja, also da wird VW wirklich abgeschrieben jetzt. Also bei solchen Sachen werden jetzt die Zöpfe abgeschnitten. Mal gucken. Und vier große Märkte sind da zu beobachten. Digital und KI Kram, Klima und Industrie Technik, Mobilität und Gesundheit. Beim Thema generative KI sagen sie, da ist ein Wachstumsspielraum von 0,6 Prozent durch Effizienzgewinne. Also wenn ich mir so anschaue, was Menschen typischerweise am Computer so machen und dann die anderen Texte schreiben, was die Hersteller der KI so versprechen, was die kann, würde ich sagen 0,6 Prozent nur. Das kommt mir ein bisschen wenig vor, aber gut. 22 Prozent der KI-Forscher in der Welt haben in Deutschland studiert, aber nur 15 Prozent arbeiten hier. Also da gibt es auch Remigrationsbemehrungen, um mal ganz scharf zu formulieren. Es dürfe nicht sein, dass in den Jahren 2015 bis 2023 allein 50 in Europa gegründete Unternehmen in den USA in die Börse gegangen seien, um dort eine Marktkapitalisierung von 439 Milliarden Dollar zu erreichen. Das hätten sie in Europa vermutlich nicht geschafft und künftig sollen sie es hier schaffen. Was bedeutet? Oberster Punkt, nachdem das abgehandelt ist, Bildungssystem, besseres Bildungssystem. Solche Sachen gehen immer schief, das wird immer ganz oben aufgehangen und die einzigen, sagen wir mal, sozialen Felder, in denen wir akzeptieren, dass es in Containern stattfindet, ist Migration und Bildung. Also dass Schulen in Bildung in Containern stattfindet. Ich bin gespannt, vielleicht wird ja hier wirklich was gemacht, aber keine Ahnung. Finanzierung der Erganer 2035 Deutschlands. Staatsschulden betrügen nur knapp 64 Prozent des BIP, die der USA läge bei 121, die von Frankreich bei 111. Entsprechend seien ausreichende Mittel für Investitionen vorhanden. Ja, das ist ein guter Satz, das ist mal so zu sagen. Die Schuldenbremse sollte, hier steht jetzt verfassungsrechtlich, und getragen von einem breiten politischen Konsens reformiert werden. Ich denke, das hat Schulz jetzt eingeläutet gestern mit der klaren Ansage, daran ist es zerbrochen, sodass zukunftsorientierte Investitionen auch jenseits der Schuldenbremse getätigt werden können. Fiskalische Disziplin ist wichtig, die Schuldenbremse darf aber keine Investitionsbremse sein. Wir wissen, diesen Satz hören wir nicht zum ersten Mal, aber man kann ihn ja auch mal mit Leben füllen. Also mal gucken. Bei den Einnahmen sollte der Staat zweitens nicht pauschal Steuern und Abgaben erhöhen. Also wir haben schon wieder keine Superreichen diskussiert. Denn denen wird ja Investitionsmöglichkeit gegeben. Zukunftskonvent. Und jetzt ist sozusagen das ist der Dreh- und Angelpunkt, weshalb das jetzt anders interessant ist als gestern, noch lustig. Wir brauchen einen Zukunftskonvent. Den großen Schulterschluss. Hier wird jetzt über die drei Berater gesagt. Die drei haben sich auch über die politische Umsetzung ihre Gedanken gemacht. Sie setzen auf einen möglichst breiten gesellschaftlichen Konsens, den es nicht braucht, aber der nicht zulasten des Umsetzungstempos gehen soll. Die Bergerberater haben sich über die politische Umsetzung ihre Gedanken gemacht und schlagen vor, kurzfristig einen parteiübergreifenden Zukunftskonvent mit Olaf Scholz, Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz und den Spitzen der anderen beiden Regierungsparteien einzuberufen. Scholz und Habe kamen ja gestern den Schulterschluss schon gemacht, haben auch schon gesagt, also März muss ich jetzt dazu verhalten, wie die sich halt verhalten, weil alle Welt wissen.
Und Scholz hat ja eine ähnliche Formulierung gebraucht. Er hat ja gesagt, dass jetzt keine Zeit ist zu warten auf Neuwahlen, bis wir Deutschland wieder auf Vordermann bringen. Das heißt, er sieht das ganz genauso. Und sagt, jetzt muss gehandelt werden.
Und jetzt lesen wir diesen Satz, von dem ich gestern noch, also ich habe den Text nur mitgebracht, weil ich diesen Satz vorlesen wollte, mit der Kommentierung HaHa, was für Naivlinge. Sie sagen, der Zukunftskonvent soll demnach im November stattfinden. Es ist übrigens gerade November. Die Arbeitsgruppen sollen über den Jahreswechsel tagen. Und die politische Entscheidung im Konsens durch Regierung und Opposition soll im Februar 2025 vorliegen.
Ja, so ein Wahnsinn.
Und im März haben wir dann eine Bundestagswahl. Also ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, ob die drei hier einfach so einen Zeitgeistpunkt getroffen haben, um jetzt einfach so eine Agenda hier zu platzieren. Und ich finde es auch nicht allzu schlecht. Sie sagen jetzt hier, breiter Konsens. Mir reicht es erstmal völlig, wenn die Schuldenbremse ernsthaft reformiert wird. Scholz hat ja gestern schon gesagt, das ist eine Notsituation. Die müssen wir jetzt auch, was ja nur wieder heißt, eine Ausnahme der Schuldenbremse. Ich finde schon, es sollte jetzt die Zeit genutzt werden, die Schuldenbremse selbst anzupassen.
Man kann nur jetzt das noch vielleicht machen. Deswegen sollte es nicht darauf hinauslaufen, dass man sich nochmal auf 50 Milliarden oder so einigt.
Merz, Habeck, Scholz haben diese verfassungsgebende Mehrheit noch im Parlament. Mal sehen, dieser Text scheint mir etwas mehr Traktion zu haben, als ich vorgestern noch dachte, als ich ihn hier vorbereitet habe.
Tja, so schnell kann es gehen. Wir wissen von den USA, dass die Inflation ein großes Problem war und sicherlich auch dafür gesorgt hat, dass Trump gewählt wurde. Das ist nicht der alleinige Grund, aber auch ein Grund. Und auch wenn diese wirtschaftlichen Kennzahlen sonst alle so wunderbar grün sind, stimmt doch vieles nicht, gerade wenn man sieht, wer eigentlich die Lasten von Inflationen besonders tragen muss. Für Deutschland hat uns das jetzt Tom Krebs aufgeschrieben in seinem Buch Fehldiagnose, wie Ökonomen die Wirtschaft ruinieren und die Gesellschaft spalten. Bei Westend ist dieses Buch erschienen. Ich will einen Kritikpunkt als erstes bringen, damit ich das gleich nicht vergesse. Und zwar geht er kurz auf das Heizungsgesetz ein und sagt, dass da manches schief lief, aber vor allem in der Kommunikation. Ich hätte gerne mal 20 Seiten dazu gelesen. Was war gut? Was war schlecht? Und bitte nicht einfach nur ein bisschen was Kommunikatives ist daneben gegangen, sondern ich hätte gerne eine Analyse gehabt, aber gibt es hier auch nicht. Gut, aber wir erfahren relativ viel zu dem, was uns umtreibt, nämlich die Inflation. Und da hat er wunderbare Statistiken parat und auch Kennzahlen, die wir uns bewusst machen sollten. Und zwar zeigt er hier eine Grafik über Verbraucherpreise. Und diese Grafik sagt uns zum einen, dass die Verbraucherpreise natürlich gestiegen sind. Aber welche Preise sind besonders eklatant gestiegen? Nun die Lebensmittelpreise und die Energiepreise. Damit, sagt Krebs, ist Folgendes festzustellen. Die Grafik unterstreicht den starken Anstieg der Lebenshaltungskosten, den die Energiekrise verursacht hat. Innerhalb von zwei Jahren haben die Preise für Energie um 50 Prozent, für Lebensmittel um 30 Prozent und für alle Verbrauchsküter um 13 Prozent zugenommen. Dieser Anstieg betraf also primär Energie und Lebensmittel, was die sozialen Kosten der Inflation hervorhebt, da beide einen großen Teil des Konsumkorbs der unteren und mittleren Einkommen ausmachen. Das muss man sich immer wieder bewusst machen. Auch wenn man hört, ja, Inflation ist jetzt bei 2 Prozent oder sie war bei 4,5 Prozent, dann haben wir sehr häufig diesen Gedanken, dass man sagt, ah, dann fehlen jetzt jedem 4,5 Prozent. Nein. Wer fast alles ausgeben muss im Monat, was er verdient, gibt das größtenteils für Energie und Lebensmittel aus. Krebs macht eine ganz einfache Rechnung. Betrachten wir eine vierköpfige Familie mit monatlichen Ausgaben für Energie von 400 Euro und für Nahrungsmittel von 800 Euro. Sehr realistisch. Insgesamt belaufen sich die monatlichen Kosten für Öl, Gas zum Heizen, Strom für Licht und Kochen, Benzin zum Autofahren und dem Einkauf der Nahrungsmittel also auf 1200 Euro. Wenn man jetzt sieht, wie sich das alles entwickelt hat in nur wenigen Monaten, dann stellen wir fest, dass für diese Familie die monatlichen Kosten für Energie und Nahrungsmittel um 440 Euro auf 1640 Euro zugenommen haben. Es fehlen also krisenbedingt jeden Monat 440 Euro in der Haushaltskasse. Und das wurde dann nicht durch irgendwelche Lohnanstiege kompensiert, sondern die Löhne stagnierten oder wuchsen zumindest nicht derart stark an. Man kann sich ja vorstellen, was sollen das für Löhne sein, die ja um 20 Prozent oder so nach oben gehen müssen. Also wir haben hier einfach 440 Euro im Monat mehr Belastung. Und damit ist dann man an einem Punkt angelangt, wo das nicht mehr weitergeht. Er sagt, die Reallöhne sanken 2022 durchschnittlich um vier Prozent. Dieser Einkommensverlust markiert den größten Rückgang des Lebensstandards für Beschäftigte in der deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte. Er hat hier eine ganz lange Grafik, die geht bis ins Jahr 1950 zurück, zeigt uns, wie da die Lohnentwicklungen waren. Er hat nicht den MSCI World dazu, den kann man sich dann mal schnell noch googeln. Dann wird einem vieles klar oder kann man auch mal den DAX sich noch ansehen. Das heißt hier für ihn, erstens verwenden Haushalte mit geringem Einkommen einen großen Teil ihres Einkommens für Energie und Lebensmittel, deren Preise besonders stark gestiegen sind. Weiter sagt er, es wird noch einige Zeit dauern, bis die während der Corona- und Energiekrise erlittenen Verluste von insgesamt fünf Prozent ausgeglichen sind und die Beschäftigten Deutschlands nennenswerten Reallongewinne im Vergleich zum Vorkrisenniveau erleben werden. Also das ist sehr wichtig, was er hier aufschreibt. Sie waren dann eingeladen. Wolfgang Schmitt vom Bundeskanzleramt hat also eine ökonomische Zeitenwendekonferenz abgehalten. Und da hat er sich also diese ganzen Vorträge angehört aus allen renommierten Instituten. Sagt er, während die versammelten Ökonomen im Bundeskanzleramt ihr Loblied auf den Markt sangen, blieb ein Punkt gänzlich unerwähnt. Die hohen Reallohnverluste der Beschäftigten im Jahr 2022. In keinem der zehn Vorträge der Wirtschaftsprofessionen wurde sich mit den Problemen auseinandergesetzt.
Ja, das wichtigste Anliegen der Wähler ging einfach irgendwie verloren. Das kommt uns jetzt nicht nur bekannt vor, sondern ganz bitter steht das als Realität vor uns in Amerika.
Es ist echt erstaunlich. Er zeigt dann auch nochmal dieses Papier der Ökonomen. Nur erinnert es sich an, als der Krieg gerade begann. Ja, wir können einfach komplett aus dem Gas rausgehen, aber wir brauchen Russland gar nicht mehr. Er schreibt hier, das sei ein kindlicher Glaube gewesen, wie sich dann zeigt. Das hätte 50 Prozent weniger Erdgas verbrauchende Industrie bedeutet. Was hätte das wiederum dann realwirtschaftlich gemeint? Wir hätten einen BIP-Minus von 8 bis 10 Prozent, statt 4 Prozent, von 8 bis 10 Prozent gehabt. Also sie, er macht das wirklich sehr gut. Er zeigt auch Probleme bei der CO2-Bepreisung, wo das dann keine Lenkungswirkung hat. Er sieht sehr düster. Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass sich Deutschland in Disneyland verwandelt?
Ganz Deutschland?
Pass auf, ich lese es dir vor. Die anhaltende Produktionsschwäche der Industrie ist bedenklich, aber noch besorgniserregender sind die ausbleibenden Investitionen im industriellen Sektor. Die steigenden Energiekosten in Kombination mit einer verfehlten Industriepolitik haben dazu geführt, dass die notwendigen Investitionen in die industrielle Zukunft Deutschlands schwach bleiben. Doch genau dies zerrt an dem künftigen Kapitalstock und es kommt zu Deindustrialisierung. Der schleichende Prozess der Deindustrialisierung kann dazu führen, dass Deutschland wie England zu einem Freizeitpark für ausländische Touristen wird, der mögliche Disneyland-Effekt der Energiekrise. Damit ist gemeint, dass die dargestellte Entwicklung dazu führen könnte, dass in Deutschland künftig ein größerer Teil der gesamtwirtschaftlichen Produktion direkt oder indirekt durch Touristen getrieben ist, die sich gern mittelalterliche Schlösser, pittoreske Universitäten oder andere Sehenswürdigkeiten anschauen.
Ich habe ja in meinem Kopf so ein Bild, ich habe es schon mal an Venedig beschrieben. Ich hätte gerne den Wiederaufbau Venedigs als reine Kulisse. Und zwar nicht als Abwertung oder nur noch Tourismus oder wie auch immer, sondern weil auch das erste, ursprüngliche Venedig nur als Kulisse konzipiert war. Ich finde, in diesen Systemstreit-Diskussionen zwischen Amerika, China und den Schlüsseltechnologien sollte Deutschland einfach sagen, es ist doch schön, wenn uns jemand die Autos baut. Das müssen wir nicht mehr selber machen, zum Glück. Aber wir laden die Welt ein, bei uns touristisch zu erleben, was in diesen beiden Regionen wirklich erlitten wird, als haben wir nicht. Zum einen in Amerika einfach zeitlich, wir haben es nicht. Und in China, das ist was anderes. In Europa, das haben wir nicht. Alle wollen das sehen. Nur eben gelebt. Es sollen echte Leben in Venedig leben. Also die Kulisse heißt nur, die Fassade ist für die Touristen. Der Rest muss echt sein. Ich bin auch total dafür, das Kolosseum in Rom wieder aufzubauen, so wie es damals war und es auch wirklich zu nutzen. Also den Boden zu schließen und dann da die großen Festivals, 100.000 Leute Brot und Spiele zu veranstalten. Aber eben nicht nur für die Touristen. Aber ich habe in der Alten Republik auch von Urlaub bis ans Lebenende gesprochen. Also diese Idee.
Also wir sind einfach dann permanent Protagonisten und aber auch Schauspieler. Nee, sagen wir Protagonisten.
Wir alle spielen Theater. Das ist ganz konform mit der Goffman.
Wir machen dann hier nochmal altes Europa.
Den Machtübernahme von Nico Semsrott. Ja. Stefan Semsrott. Stand dieser Satz drin. Wenn die politische Welt um dich zerbricht, dann kümmere dich um deine eigene Lebenswelt und lebe schon mal als ob. Und diese Idee will ich einfach, ich möchte, dass wir hier kultiviert im sozialen nahen Bereich leben. Dass wir unsere Privatsphären unter Kontrolle haben, weil wir einfach uns gerne in ihnen aufhalten, statt sie uns von der Politik zertrümmern zu lassen. Der Ansicht, ich finde es gut, dass der Krebs das so formuliert und es skandalisiert über nur für Touristen. Denn ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir das machen, aber eben nicht nur für Touristen.
Ich werde es noch mal mit Maurice Hülfgen vielleicht besprechen, ob man da volkswirtschaftlich einen Griff dran bekommt. Ich habe so meine Zweifel, aber gut. Er sagte auch, dass Ende 2023 die Reallöhne rund zehn Prozent unter ihrem Vorkrisentrend lagen. Und das ist ganz interessant. Also es gibt ja einen Reallohn und der ist gesunken, wie wir wissen. Aber es gab ja einen Reallohntrend. Das heißt, man guckt sich über die vergangenen 15 Jahre an, wie die Reallöhne etwas gestiegen sind und schaut dann, wo müssten die eigentlich, wenn dieser Trend weitergegangen wäre, heute stehen. Und dann kommt man genau dabei an. Das heißt also, dass die Leute die größten Verluste erlitten haben, die vor allem ihre Löhne ausgeben müssen, die also jetzt nicht eine große Sparrate haben. Er beschäftigt sich auch kurz mit dem grünen Wachstum. Auch das finde ich ganz interessant, wie er da von Effizienzgewinnen spricht und da auch Ulrike Herrmann widerspricht. Und wie er sich auch nochmal ganz klar ausspricht, dass es eine Politik um Lohnerhöhungen geben muss. Es muss 15 Euro Mindestlohn her und und und. Also wir haben hier mal eine ökonomische Perspektive auf die Löhne und deren Entwicklung. Und deswegen finde ich dieses Buch wichtig, dass es jetzt erscheint.
Sehr gut. Der Krebs ist eher die Klocken. Philippa Siegel Klöckner hat ihn auch zitiert. Mit der Bildungsrendite. 14 Prozent war eine Rechnung von ihm. Dario Amodei ist Chef von Anthropic und hat den Text geschrieben. Machines of Loving Grace. Und er platziert sich kurz als ich bin Chef von so einer Firma, die das macht. Und ich denke, wir sollten hier unsere Ideen nicht unter, sondern mal öffentlich damit umgehen. Denn es gibt hier Risiken und Benefits, die beide unterschätzt werden. Also wenn mal gesagt wird, alles ist gefährlich, erst ist alles gefährlich, aber nur weil man einfach diese Gewichtung nicht drin hat. Man kann diese Gefahr durchaus bändigen, so wie man den schöpferischen Steil gestalten könnte, wenn man es nur politisch macht und so. Also von der Anlage her finde ich es ganz gut. Und er will jetzt so ein Szenario beschreiben, was wäre, wenn alles richtig läuft? Also wenn es einfach, er entwirft so einen, er macht Szenarioplanung. Also angenommen, die negativen Aspekte gibt es nicht. Und was wären positive Benefits, wenn man sie doch nur gestaltet? Und das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant, aber man findet es auch ein bisschen komisch, deswegen werde ich punktuell mal vorlesen. Ihm ist zu viel Sci-Fi-Semantik, sei noch gesagt. Während ich, oder können wir dann später überprüfen, denken, nee, bist du nicht selber jetzt der Sky-Fi im Quadrat Typ. Aber gut, also wir wissen ja, dass Google vor allem sich an Raumschiff Enterprise und diese ganzen Sachen da orientierte. Ich glaube sogar, es ist, dass es entscheidend ist, eine wirklich inspirierende Vision der Zukunft zu haben und nicht nur einen Plan zur Brandbekämpfung, also fünf Themenfelder werden aufgemacht. Biologie und Gesundheit, Neurowissenschaft und geistige Gesundheit, wissenschaftliche Entwicklung und Armut, Frieden und Regierungsführung, Arbeit und Bedeutung, Sinngebung. Was machen wir in unserem Leben? Vorhersagen sind schwierig. Er macht sie nach den Maßstäben, die wir haben, aber radikal. Es soll Inspiration sein oder auch Aufforderungen an Experten, der Felder, über die er jetzt schreibt, sich da selber mal einzubringen. Und eine sachkundigere Vision zu schreiben. Also in der Ansicht schon ganz interessant, dass er sich da selber so ein bisschen mit großen Ideen vorstellt, aber zurücknimmt als ich bin jetzt derjenige, dem man da unbedingt folgen sollte. Schon 2026 kann es nämlich so weit sein, dass wir uns ernsthaft andere Fragen stellen müssen. Und er möchte gerne über die fünf bis zehn Jahre nach so einer Wende schreiben. Wir haben bisher so von OpenAI diesen AGI-Discourse, also die General Intelligence. Und er sagt jetzt, naja, das ist alles blöd. Wir reden mal von Powerful AI. Also künstliche Intelligenz, die bei den Fragen, die sie beantwortet, einfach das Doktorandentum weit übersteigt. Also die einfach auf allen Fächern und allen Feldern und die genauer beobachten kann und was auch immer. Und diese fünf bis zehn Jahre treiben sich so durch den Text. Also kommt er immer wieder drauf zurück. In dieser Biologie-Sparte zum Beispiel sagt er, hier sieht er das größte Verbesserungspotenzial. Die Rendite der Intelligenz könnte kaum höher sein als in der Biologie. Denn das Forschungsfeld wurde bisher bestimmt durch ganz wenige Grundlagen Forschungsergebnisse, auf denen dann mega viel aufgebaut wurde. Also irgendeine kleine Verkettung von irgendwelchen Molekülen. Und zack, hat man eine ganz neue Industrie. Und er fragt sich jetzt, ob man nicht den Fortschritt nach bisherigem Maßstab verzehnfachen könnte. Also in den nächsten zehn Jahren Fortschritt von 100 Jahren. Wie auch immer. Ich würde jetzt sagen, ne, Fortschritt ist erst mal Fortschritt, egal wie man verrechnet. Und so richtig, glaube ich, finden wir auch keinen. Also es ist halt immer so sprunghaft gewesen, wenn jetzt mehrere Sprünge sind. Aber gut, er sagt, beobachtenswert ist, noch effizientere, noch selektivere CRISPR-Technik, also einfach die Gene da neu zu sortieren. Fortschrittliche Zelltherapie, Durchbrüche in der Materialwissenschaft und Miniaturisierung, also noch kleinere Computer, Computer auf anderen Materialien, was auch immer, alles sozusagen noch im Biologiekapitel. Bessere Kontrolle über Stammzellen, Zelldifferenzierung, Enddifferenzierung und die daraus resultierten Fähigkeiten, Gewebe nachwachsen zu lassen oder neu zu formen. Also sozusagen synthetisches Leben, meint er hier. Bessere Kontrolle über das Immunsystem, gezieltes Einschalten zur Bekämpfung von Krebs und Infektionskrankheiten oder eben gezieltes Abschalten zur Bekämpfung von Autoimmunkrankheiten. Wir wissen ja, dass daran wirklich sehr intensiv geforscht wird. Er meint, 1000 Jahre Fortschritt in fünf bis zehn Jahren kann passieren. 100 Jahre in nur einem Jahr ist er eher skeptisch. Ich weiß nicht genau, was solche Denkfiguren sollen, aber...
Wie misst man das denn? Wann sagt man dann, jetzt hat es sich verzehnfacht? Ich kann das ja bei einer Handykamera sagen, jetzt hat man so und so viele Pixel.
Das ist noch Auflösung. Das ist ein bisschen unklar. Also diese Zahlenspielerei, ich weiß nicht, er wollte jetzt ein bisschen illustrativ rein. mRNA-Covid-Impfungen haben ja schon gezeigt, wie ungewöhnlich schnell es sein kann, Sachen zu entwickeln und zuzulassen. Nur es ging trotzdem zu langsam. Also er möchte sozusagen, selbst die schnellste Anpassung einer neuen Technik, weil wir sie einfach brauchten, das waren ja immer noch von Februar bis Oktober, da man sie dann kam. Das ist nicht mal für außergewöhnlich. Als Standard wäre es auch zu langsam. Er will einfach alles grundsätzlich schnell haben. Wir brauchen eine Liste. Niveau des Radikalismus, Impfstoffe für alles, Krebs ausrotten, Embryo-Screening, Alzheimer verhindern, biologische Freiheit, also die komplette Unterwerfung des Körpers. Im Grunde diese Idee, du formst dich digital, machst irgendwelche Filter, machst das doch in echt. Geh einfach zu der nächsten biologischen Anlaufstelle und sag, ich möchte wie beim Friseur diese Frisur haben und dann wird dein Körper irgendwie hin und her gerichtet, wie auch immer. Dann hat er so einen Punkt, den will ich mal vorlesen. Sobald die menschliche Lebensspanne 150 Jahre beträgt, können wir vielleicht Fluchtgeschwindigkeit erreichen und so genug Zeit gewinnen, dass die meisten der heute lebenden Menschen so lange leben können, wie sie wollen, obwohl es sicherlich keine Garantie dafür gibt, dass dies biologisch möglich ist. Also, wenn wir jetzt einen kleinen biologischen Fortschritt in der Forschung machen, der uns eine Lebensspanne von 150 Jahren ermöglicht, schaffen wir es innerhalb dieser 150 Jahre, denen dann Lebenden unendliches Leben zu geben. Solche Ideen werden ja.
Ja, aber er schlägt noch nicht vor, dass man einfach die Menschen züchtet. Es geht ja schon sehr nahe.
Moment, Moment. Also, ja, so richtig züchten nicht. Also, diese Idee, die wir letztens hatten, aber wir nähern uns. Zum Thema Neurowissenschaft und Geist geht er so vor wie bei den somatischen Krankheiten. Im Grunde hat er so einen Seiburg vor Augen. Implantate und Intervention selbst im Gehirn völlig normal. Er schreibt dann Instrumente zur Messung und Intervention. Insbesondere am lebenden Menschen werden wahrscheinlich zu einer schnellen Iteration und zu Fortschritten führen. Die Umstrukturierung des Gehirns klingt schwierig, aber es scheint auch eine Aufgabe zu sein, die sich für die Intelligenz lohnt. Vielleicht gibt es eine Möglichkeit, das erwachsene Gehirn in einen früheren oder plastischeren Zustand zu bringen, in dem es umgestaltet werden kann. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das möglich ist, aber mein Instinkt lässt mich optimistisch sein, was die KI hier erfinden kann.
Oh Gott.
Upload von Gedanken, warum nicht? Wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und Armut.
Das ist dann der Film mit Johnny Depp, Transcendence.
Genau. Als ich so einen Solarpark aufbaute, dann einfach fort. Ich bin nicht so zuversichtlich, also das muss man jetzt mal im Kontrast sehen. Wir hatten jetzt Kapitel, also tausende, hunderte Worte dann, wo einfach steht, Eingriffe ins Gehirn, gar kein Problem, Umgestaltung des Körpers, gar kein Problem, jetzt, ich bin nicht so zuversichtlich, dass KI die Ungleichheit und das Wirtschaftswachstum lösen kann.
Ach so.
Also da sind jetzt natürliche Grenzen. Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ich bin etwas skeptisch, dass eine KI das berühmte sozialistische Berechnungsproblem, ich sag jetzt mal die Planwirtschaft, lösen könnte, also kein Cybersint, wie damals in Chile, oder wo die das gemacht haben, erschreibt, es ist plausibel, dass KI-Finanzminister und Zentralbanker über zehn Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum organisieren können. Also mal sehen, wer nach Cookies dann im Wirtschaftsministerium folgt.
Die KI einfach, ja.
Wirtschaftswachstum, der heute am besten laufenden Länder, nämlich die auf niedrigem Niveau gerade Entwicklungssprünge machen, sollten eigentlich durchweg alle übertroffen werden. Insbesondere die Südsahara-Afrika-Region könnte in den nächsten zehn Jahren chinesisches Wirtschaftswachstumsniveau erreichen, sagte er. Mal gucken. Frieden. Er sieht hier optimistischerweise ein ewiges 1991. Wir erinnern uns, die Mauer ist gefallen. Es gab Anlässe, Bücher zu schreiben über das Ende der Geschichte. Und ein ewiges 1991 ginge, wenn ein Gleichgewicht zwischen Zuckerbrot und Peitscher, also Carrot and Stick im Originalenglisch, durch kluge Entscheidungen herbeigeführt werden kann. Dank KI. Also ich will noch mal ausdrücklich sagen, das ist der Anthropik-Chef hier, also der Klote so in Verantwortung hat.
Das ist ja so verrückt, dass jemand wie Jean Baudrillard das als Horrorszenario uns zeichnet und 20 Jahre später kommt jemand und sagt, also das wäre erstrebenswert, da kämen wir auch hin, wenn wir Folgendes tun.
Ich will jetzt mal einen Text zum politischen Governance, einen Text vorlesen, in dem die Worte Demokratie, Demokratie, Demokratie fallen und wir denken uns jetzt an Autokratie, Autokratie, Autokratie. Ich bin optimistisch, dass in einem globalen Umfeld, in dem Demokratien die mächtigste KI kontrollieren, dann KI die Demokratie tatsächlich überall strukturell begünstigen könnte. Insbesondere können demokratische Regierungen in einem solchen Umfeld ihre überlegene KI nutzen, um den Informationskrieg zu gewinnen. Ich frage mich so, warum sollte das für Autokratie nicht gelten? Ja, es gibt gar keinen logischen Grund. Ja, an der Ansicht, hm hm hm. Gut, ein Punkt hier unten noch. Smarte Verträge in Kryptowährungen haben das Recht nicht revolutioniert, weil gewöhnlicher Code nicht intelligent genug ist, um so viel von Interesse zu entscheiden. Aber KI könnte dafür intelligent genug sein. Sie ist die erste Technologie, die in der Lage ist, umfassende unscharfe Urteile auf wiederholbare und mechanische Weise zu fällen. Also die Politik und das Justizwesen möchte er gerne an die KI auslagern. Das ist seine, wenn es richtig gut läuft, Strategie.
Können die nicht einfach einen Assistenten machen, der uns ein bisschen am Alltag hilft und ansonsten den Mund halten?
Du suchst also Unterstützung, um ein besseres Leben zu fühlen. Zum Thema Arbeit schreibt er, wäre doch schön, wenn die Menschen nur noch sinnstiftende Arbeit machen. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, das widerspricht nun wirklich aller Philosophie und Erfahrung, dass wir, wenn wir uns von Lasten befreien und so weiter und so fort, dann zu Sinnstiftung kommen. Ja, also wenn wir Belastung rausnehmen, ist sozusagen, ja, wird glaube ich auch nicht aufgehen. Aber die KI macht den ökonomischen Teil der Arbeit und der Mensch macht was Sinnvolles. Ja, aber du wirst dich noch wundern, letzter Satz dazu. Wir Menschen werden von den Leistungen der KI, Zitat, zu Tränen gerührt werden, weil wir endlich unsere Freiheit ausleben können. Toll.
Ich habe einen Artikel gelesen, der ist in The Baffler erschienen. Francis Northwood hat ihn verfasst. Es geht um das große Wetten, um die unsicheren Wetten. Nämlich der Polymarkt. The Polymarkets sind jetzt in aller Munde. Auch deshalb, weil immer mal wieder Elon Musk und auch andere Trump-Anhänger von diesen Wetten, was sie berichtet haben, bei Twitter haben Screenshots gepostet, haben gezeigt, dass Trump jetzt ganz vorne ist bei diesen Wetten. Also es geht um eine Plattform, auf der man wetten kann, auf zum Beispiel die Wahlergebnisse, wie sie ausfallen. Das ist zum Teil eigentlich rechtlich gar nicht erlaubt, für Amerikaner das zu tun, aber man findet natürlich Mittel und Wege. In England gibt es da schon viel. Nate Silver ist so ein Orakel, deshalb, weil er ein Meinungsforschungsinstitut gründete und dort auch sich immer wieder äußerte, wer die nächste Wahl gewinnte.
Und die NBA Spiele.
Und die NBA Spiele. Also es geht beides zusammen. 538 hieß die. Und dieser Nate Silver ist aber nun eingestiegen bei einem Unternehmen namens Polymarket. Polymarket ist eine dezentralisierte Wettplattform. Eine Wettwebseite, auf der Wetten in Kryptowährungen platziert werden, auf der Nutzer auf so ziemlich alles wetten können. Mit der Kryptowährung ist es natürlich dann auch schon besser zu verschleiern, von wo aus die Wetten überhaupt stattfinden. Die Arten von Wetten oder Prognosemärkten, die dort angeboten werden, werden von den Nutzern über die Messaging-Plattform Discord eingereicht. Wenn sie ein paar davon durchgehen, bekommen sie schnell einen Eindruck, was das für ein Ort ist. Sieger der Premier League? Wird Israel im September in den Libanon einmarschieren? Waren in den letzten Monaten auf der Homepage von Polymarket zu finden. Auch bei diesen Wetten geht es um erstaunlich viel Geld. Mehr als 13 Millionen Dollar wurden darauf gesetzt, ob Israel im September in den Libanon einmarschieren wird. Und zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung dieses Artikels wurden über 3 Milliarden Dollar darauf gewettet, wer die Präsidentschaftswahlen gewinnen wird, also kurz vorher erschienen. Im Oktober dieses Jahres setzte sich der 26-jährige Gründer von Polymarket, Shane Copeland, auf der Mainnet, dem größten jährlichen Krypto-Evente New York, um von Nate Silver interviewt zu werden. Dort erzählte Copeland die Entstehungsgeschichte von Polymarket. Und zwar sagte er sich zu Beginn der Pandemie, wir brauchen mehr Prognosemärkte. Und dann hätte man das auch viel besser wissen können, alles mit dem Maskenmangel, wann ist dieser vorbei? Also das ist so die Argumentation. Denn so ein Wettmarkt, der produziert doch Wissen. Der weiß ja am Ende viel mehr, als ein Einzelner wissen kann. Also wir sehen hier schon, das ist so diese marktliberale Idee, die hier zur Perfektion oder zur Absurdität getrieben wird.
Also ich will es mal kurz so sagen, während wir von den Polls immer gehört haben, es steht 50-50. Und wir aber heute wissen, es stand mehr so 60-40. Auf den Wettmärkten wurde das mit 60-40 verhandelt, das Trump-Gewinn.
Ganz genau. Der Artikel erscheint ein paar, ich glaube zwei Tage vor, der Wahl. Und hier steht, im Moment kostet eine Harris-wird-gewinnen-Aktie etwas weniger als 41 Cent. Was heißt das? Also laut Polymarket hat Harris also eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 41 Prozent, die Präsidentschaft zu gewinnen. Wer ist mit im Game, also wer ist mit Risikokapital da reingegangen? Peter Thiel ist investiert. Dann Vitalik Buterin, der Erfinder von Ethereum und dann noch andere aus der Tech-Welt. Tatsächlich hat Buterin auf X rund heraus bestritten, dass Polymarket eine Glücksspielplattform sei. Er schrieb, dass Polymarket stattdessen als soziales, epistemisches Werkzeug gesehen werden sollte, dass der Öffentlichkeit hilft, einen Überblick darüber zu bekommen, wie wichtig bestimmte Ereignisse sind und welche Art von Dingen wahrscheinlich passieren werden.
Dem ist auch, also wir kriegen jeden Abend diese DAX-Werte. Ja. Und es gibt keine richtige Rechtfertigung, warum man das nicht bei anderen Themen auch macht. Man kann alles finanzialisieren und über Preise ausdrücken.
Ist die Frage, ob man das, ob das gut ist, das zu machen, denn es ist natürlich auch anfällig für Manipulation. Man weiß nämlich zum Beispiel nicht, wer da drei Millionen Dollar auf Trump gesetzt hat. Und man weiß auch nicht, weil die Akteure heißen irgendwie TO334, man weiß nicht, wenn die gegen Unternehmen wetten, ob die nicht zugleich an der Börse Aktien gekauft, verkauft haben, ob die Shorten oder irgendetwas machen. Also ob darüber eine Beeinflussung stattfindet. Die Frage ist natürlich auch, kann ich irgendwann so weit gehen, dass ich dort eine hoch riskante Wette mache? Weil ja hier auch gefragt wird, wie wird Sinn wahr den Gaserstreifen verlassen? Und damit ist gemeint, Leben verlassen und sowas. Also ob nicht am Ende die lukrative Wette zu Straftaten führen kann, auch das ist nicht klar.
Inzwischen sind da 200.000 Monat, dass sie jemanden töten, um den Wetteinsatz zu…
Naja, könnte man ja machen. Also das steht ja nicht im Text, aber das habe ich jetzt dahinterpretiert, dass das möglich ist. Dann gibt es da 200.000 monatliche aktive Händler und es ist schon so wichtig geworden, also es ist jetzt nicht nur so für ein paar Krypto-Pros, dass Bloomberg da schon sehr genau draufschaut. Dann heißt es hier, in einem informellen Gespräch im letzten Frühjahr erzählte mir ein Blackrock-Mitarbeiter ganz sachlich, dass das Unternehmen wichtige interne Entscheidungen trifft, die teilweise auf den Polymarket-Quoten basieren. Auch eine interessante Sache, wir wissen ja, Insider-Handel an der Börse ist verboten, aber hier bin ich ja anonym. Das heißt, ich kann ja Insider sein, kann dann die Aktie nicht kaufen, kann aber auf dem Polymarket mein Unwesen treiben.
Das sind ja Versuche, über Technologie Wissen zu erzeugen. Und wir haben ja vorhin ein Buch gelesen, das sich auch Gedanken macht, um Wissen zu erzeugen zu einem Thema. Und Reckwitz hat ja die ganze Zeit so ein Gedankenmodell von, in welchem Verhältnis steht eigentlich das zudem und so. Hier kann man sich diese Frage ernsthaft stellen. In welchem Verhältnis steht eigentlich diese Wissensfindung Polymarkets zur Gesellschaft? Weil die Gesellschaft wirkt immer zurück. Also es ist ja ein Geben und Nehmen und am Ende unterm Strich zähle ich, wird ja abgerechnet. Also es ist auch so ein Teufelsküche-Thema.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ein hochinteressantes Thema, das uns wahrscheinlich jetzt immer begleiten wird bei den Wahlen.
Jetzt will ich einen Punkt kurz aufgreifen. Du meintest, das wird auch als Wissensquelle genutzt für Fragen, die man sich stellt, wenn außergewöhnliche Ereignisse passieren wie Corona. Das heißt, hier geht es auch um das Verarbeiten von Problemen, von denen man bisher keinen richtigen Umgang gefunden hat. Und jetzt fand dieser Trump-Wahl statt und vier Autoren kümmern sich hier in der New York Times um die Frage, ob hinter der Wut der Wähler noch was anderes steckt, nämlich nachklingender Covid-Kummer. Um es mal so auf Deutsch zu übersetzen. Sie interviewen hier eine Pfarrerin Amy Greene, die ansonsten sehr viel Erfahrung mit Seelsorge hat und nun sagt, hinter der Wut steckt Angst. Kennt man ja soweit das Bild. Für die Amerikaner ist es sehr viel einfacher, in einer trauerfobischen Welt wütend zu sein, weil sie das leichter in Aktionismus umwandeln können. Dann wird man nicht nur ein Trump-Wähler, sondern dann auch ein überzeugter und handelnder Trump-Wähler. Also man lebt es dann besonders aus. Was aber umso mehr bedeutet, hier hätte man auch die Nachwehen von Corona, das ist die Frage, welche Inflation wurde einfach ausgeblendet. Also die Cost of Living Crisis, die in England ja ein großes Thema war. In Amerika war es zum Beispiel so nicht. Also wurde immer nur betont, ja das wird gerade übersehen. Die Leute sagen, es ist zu teuer, aber keiner rechnet nach, also so ungefähr. Und Amerika ist nun kein großer Fan von Verletzlichkeit, die ja zu so einer Ich-leide, also braucht es eine Therapie, sondern da hat einfach jemand gehandelt, also da geht jetzt jemand aktiv rein. Das wird dann unterstützt von Pew Research Center, die auch sagen, das Vertrauen in den Institutionen ist wirklich auf historischem Tiefstand. Und laut Gallup-Umfrage haben die Amerikaner noch nie so negativ über ihre Geistegesundheit geredet, wie am Ende von 2022, als das erhoben wurde. Da könnte man natürlich da so eine ist es schon recovered oder nicht Geschichte einfach aufziehen. Und käme also zu Erklärung und einer, also ein so ein finaler konzeptioneller Gedanke ist hier, der wird natürlich, wie das so ist in den New York Times, ewig lang mit Empirie und haben mit dem geredet und da und hier 1000 Baustellen. Aber es gibt eine Mental Health America, ein Geschäftsführer dieser Mental Health America Institution, die sich um solche Fragen kümmert, der sagt, ich denke, dass einige der Wähler versuchen, die Uhr auf 2016 zurückzustellen vor Covid. Die letzte Erfahrung vor der Katastrophe war Donald Trump regiert. Ich möchte diesen Zustand wieder haben, so ungefähr. Fand ich irgendwie ganz interessant. Gut, das war der gefühlige Teil.
Aber könnte man nicht sagen, Donald Trump hat ja in der Krise auch regiert. Also Corona war ja da, die Impfung kam ja erst als Beidem, dann im Amt war.
Das wurde auch häufiger als betont bei Mosty Journal und so. Das wird Trump nicht angelastet. Also, dass es da zu Turbulenzen kam, war einfach der Himmel viel auf Amerika. Und er war gerade Präsident. Man leitet er mit ihm, dass er seine eigene Agenda nicht weiter auf Dort sitzt. Also so ungefähr. Die Präsidentenagenda wurde torpediert. Also da sieht man sich eher im Boot mit Trump. Das eigene Leben geriet aus den Fugen. Also dass er eine Aufgabe ist, beschütze uns, verhüte uns und was auch immer, wird da gar nicht so gesehen. Aber die Amerikaner sind ja auch anders drauf. Also die denken ja anders über ihr Verhältnis zur Politik. Also jetzt ist ja diese präsidiale Agenda einfach, das würde man ja im Kanzleramt nie so irgendwie. Also wir sehen uns ja sehr kritisch, wenn ein Finanzminister plötzlich eine Agenda hat. Das ist ja da ein bisschen anders. Gut, als zweites, aber wirklich nur verlinkt, es gibt eine britische Publikation, die heißt Byline Times, in der wird seit fünf Jahren so ein bisschen vor sich hin kommentiert. Das ist jetzt ein Text von Nafis Ahmed, erschienen, American Carnage, also Blutbad, das ist ja eine der Worte, die Trump in seiner ersten Amtsentführung verwandt. Der Musk-Trump-Plan für den totalen Zusammenbruch. Also wir haben jetzt hier Amerikaner, die eigentlich trauern, aber das in so eine illegitime Wut übersetzen. Wut heißt, sie können aktiv werden, es gibt etwas zu handeln, sie können es ausleben. Jetzt haben sie jemanden gewählt, der für sie etwas ausleben soll. Und derjenige kam mit Versprechen, wie alle Grenzen zu, Migranten raus, Zölle hoch, wir schaffen das selber, wie auch immer. Was ist jetzt, wenn das eingefordert wird und die Politik kann es nicht liefern, sondern nur eskalieren? Und hier wird diese Zeitspanne genannt, zwischen die Nazis übernehmen die Macht durch demokratische Prozesse und sie beschließen im Hinterzimmer eine Endlösung. Und das waren damals acht Jahre. Ich finde das so krass, aber ich finde es so richtig, dass man einfach jetzt alles auf den Tisch legt. Es muss jetzt alles durchdiskutiert werden. Niemand soll jetzt mit politischer Korrekness oder was auch immer darf man das sagen. Wir haben jetzt gesehen, die Politik traut sich alles zu, die sagt einfach alles auf der Bühne und dass hier solche reflexiven Texte jetzt entstehen, in denen einfach auch mal durchreflektiert wird, was etwas bedeutet, wenn man die Linien einfach weiterzieht. Finde ich gut. Ich werde aber nicht aus dem Text lesen, sondern den kann dann jeder einfach selber.
Und dieser Text ist wo jetzt erschienen?
Byline Times heißt die Seite. Okay. Die gibt es auch gedruckt. Das ist eine gedruckte Zeitung, die seit 2019 in England.
Aber ja, Quelle, die seriös ist in dem Sinne.
Die zumindest nicht unseriös ist. Also wir haben uns jetzt nicht mit irgendwas völlig abseitigend zu tun, sondern wie gesagt, das wird in der Bundesregierung gelesen. Ach ja. Ich kann dir das hier mal zeigen.
Also in der Bundesregierung wird es gelesen?
Naja, also jemand hat nachgefragt, bei jemandem von dem man weiß, er arbeitet in der Bundesregierung, wie informiert er euch gerade? Und dann kam dieser Text. Das ist das aktuelle Cover, das ist ein Patiersdama mit so einem Eigenhalt. Also wir werden aus unseren Sachen diskutiert. Ich würde sagen, eine gute Publikation, die so groß liegt.
Also die Bundesregierung ist da schon auf Wissen stand.
Die Bundesregierung liest da mit.
Ich stelle kurz einen Text von Daisy Jones aus der Vogue vor. Sie hat sich mit einem TikTok-Trend befasst, der heißt Sleep Maxing. Hast du davon schon gehört?
Nein, aber ich finde solche Konzepte sind sicherlich interessant. Ich habe gehört, Cristiano Ronaldo schläft nicht einmal in der Nacht, sondern alle vier Stunden für zehn Minuten oder so.
Ja, das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte, die es mal gab. Die hat sich aber dann wieder so ein bisschen verflüchtigt. Darüber hat man relativ viel gelesen.
Also, Sleep Maxing ist auf jeden Fall ein desiderat für uns alle. Alle wollen mehr schlafen. Ich kenne niemanden, der sagt, ich schlaf genug.
Ich schlaf genug.
Ah ja, dann bist du der Erste.
Also ich schlafe jetzt, wo ich das Rauchen aufgegeben habe. Und weniger Alkohol trinke, schlafe ich noch besser.
Das finde ich gut. Du sitzt 22 Uhr da, fragst dich, was könnte mein neues Ritual sein? Und du ziehst die Pantoffeln aus und gehst ins Bett.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich gehe immer noch zur selben Zeit ins Bett. Also ich gehe immer gegen 0 Uhr, halb eins ins Bett. Und ich schlafe sieben Stunden. Und ich schlafe sieben Stunden durch. Ich weiß nur, wenn man jetzt schon mal hier, wie wir hier in der Bar hoch die Tassen und noch Zigaretten, dann schläft man unruhiger und dann wird man auch mal wach. Aber wenn man jetzt wirklich nur abends eine Tasse Tee trinkt und geht dann ins Bett, schlafe ich. Ja, Oolong nicht. Oolong hat ja Koffein drin. Da muss man etwas anderes aussuchen. Aber bei mir genau mich interessiert der Trend, weil es diesen Trend gibt. Also nicht aus persönlichen Gründen. Bei mir ist es so, ich gehe ins Bett. Drei Minuten später bin ich eingeschlafen. Und dann findet man mich nach sieben Stunden wieder wach. Hier ist es so, dass es aber darum geht, den Schlaf zu maximieren. Und da gibt es momentan unter dem Hashtag Sleep Maxing 98 Millionen Posts auf TikTok, schreibt die Autorin. Und es gibt da also einen neuen Hack, wie man den Schlaf maximiert. Das ist jetzt aber keine Empfehlung. Und zwar Magnesium Supplements einnehmen, TVs essen, den Mund zukleben, zwei Stunden vor dem Schlafen gehen, nichts mehr trinken, in einem eiskalten Raum schlafen. Sie verstehen, worauf ich hinaus will. Erwartungsgemäß ist ein Großteil des Sleep-Maxing-Contents im Internet weniger darauf ausgerichtet, sich gut zu fühlen, sondern vielmehr gut auszusehen. Es gibt außerdem viele junge Männer, die in dieser Nische führend sind. Besserer Schlaf, gleich definiertere Konturen und bessere Figuren. Aber letztendlich ist Sleep-Maxing nur ein neuer Begriff für eine sehr alte Obsession, genug Schlaf zu bekommen und diesen über alle anderen Dinge zu stellen, wie zum Beispiel auszugehen oder Spaß zu haben. Nun ist es ja so, dass das eine ist ja die Frage, wie schläft man? Schläft man gut, unruhig oder sonst was? Aber hier geht es ja um sehr viel mehr. Also hier sagt sie, wird eigentlich das Schlafen auch wieder zu einer Arbeit. Das heißt, man hat nicht das Schlafen einfach als eine Ruhephase, sondern auch dabei muss was passieren. Auch man muss sich beim Schlafen noch quälen. Es leuchtet mir jetzt nicht ein, dass es besonders angenehm ist, sich den Mund zuzukleben. Wahrscheinlich hat das dann irgendeinen positiven Effekt auf die Lungen oder so. Das mag sein, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich möchte so ja nicht schlafen. Das heißt, sie sagt hier...
Das ist nicht gut für die Haut, das ist nicht gut für Skin-Maxing.
Hier wird jedenfalls auch wieder die Arbeit mit reingebracht, das Ganze. Und ihre Beschreibung geht dann auch so weiter, dass sie selbst lange Zeit versucht hat, die Schlafstörungen im Griff zu bekommen durch Schlaftracking-Apps, durch alle möglichen Dinge, mit denen sie sich befasst hat, Maßnahmen getroffen, sie hat keine Bildschirme mehr angehabt, Licht aus um 23 Uhr, Melatonin und was weiß ich, was sie da alles gemacht hat. Und dann ist sie aufgefallen, das Schlafen, das ich doch eigentlich mal mochte, ist jetzt plötzlich ein ganz anstrengendes Ritual, das ich jedes Mal absorbieren muss. Und sie sagt dann, falls ich über die Jahre mit meiner Schlafbesessenheit einen wirklichen wichtigen Schlafhack entdeckt habe, dann diesen. Am besten ist es einfach locker damit umzugehen. Und sie sagt, es ist zwar ärgerlich, wenn man mal nicht so gut schläft, wenn man ein paar unruhige Nächte hat, aber es wird auch wieder besser. Und wenn man das nicht so überfrachtet, damit, dass man sich hier optimiert und dass wenn man schlecht schläft, man gleich hässlich wird oder nicht mehr arbeiten kann oder dement wird, dann bringt diese Gelassenheit es eigentlich schon mit sich, dass man dann noch besser schläft. Und dem würde ich mich mal anschließen wollen.
Gut, also Gabriel Joran war ganz früher, bevor es Smartphones gab, hat er so eine App gemacht, Aki Aki oder so hieß die. Da hat man seinen Bluetooth angemacht und ist draußen rumgelaufen. Und dann hat man die so, hat man mal geguckt und dann, ah, da ist jemand in der Nähe, also in Bluetooth empfangen. Und dann kann man sich umgucken, wer das ist und darüber soziale Netze so spannen. Super Idee, damals genau auf Augenhöhe mit den technischen Möglichkeiten. Und wir wissen ja heute, so wird immer noch in China der Widerstand organisiert, bis Apple dem Befehl durch China kam, AirDrop zu unterbinden, also dass iPhones einfach direkt miteinander WLAN-Verbindung aufbauen und dann Flyer geteilt werden, wie auch immer. Danach, als ich bei der FAZ war, habe ich mal eine Veranstaltung besucht, die mir vorher im Internet unterkam, die hieß Quelltext-Lesung. Es war also eine Literaturbesprechung, aber eben von Software. Ich war dann in Berlin bei Wikimedia und da wurde einfach einen Abend lang die Software, also der Code, direkt auf dem Beamer angezeigt und besprochen, mit dem man auf den Mond gelandet ist oder so. Also den die Frau noch. Buchstabe für Buchstabe, Zeichen für Zeichen da und so. Dann hat er Steady mitgegründet, was wir jetzt auch nutzen. Ist aber glaube ich da nicht mehr an Bord. Und hat damals schon, nachdem er so promoviert hat zu Themen wie objektoorientierte Programmierung, also wo es so mehr um die Verkettung an sich eigenständiger Entitäten, die dann so ein autopoetisches System irgendwie hoch emergieren, ist dann glaube ich das richtige Wort, wie auch immer. Und er hat jetzt ein weiteres Buch über klassische Musik geschrieben, das heißt Schleichwege zur Klassik. Weil sein Hintergrund ist, die Eltern spielen einfach hier im HR-Sinfonieorchester, sagen Sohn, spiel Klavier, er spielt sieben Jahre Klavier, sagt ich hab da keine Lust und bereut das jetzt Jahrzehnte später. Und hat also für sich Wege zur Klassik gefunden, hat jetzt für sich Wege als Zuhörer zur Klassik gefunden. Und dieses Buch ist so aufgebaut, wie man auch Musik hört, also man sucht sich ein Werk raus und konsumiert es. Er nennt also Werke, er gibt Impressionen, Rezeptionserfahrungen wieder, wie auch immer. Und in dem Buch selbst sind dann einfach QR-Codes. Also man kann in ganz kleinen Häppchen so zwei Seiten über irgendeine Malersinfonie lesen und dann klickt man da drauf und hört sich sie einfach an. Weil man hat ja sein Smartphone dabei. Ja, sehr gut. Schleichwege in die Klassik ist wirklich ein perfekt passender Titel für das Anliegen und die Umsetzung. Also es ist ein selten guter Titel, weil es wirklich ein Schmückerbuch ist. Deswegen, ich habe es jetzt auch nicht gelesen. Es liegt halt einfach bei mir digital rum. Und dann kann man einfach so, man weiß dann, okay, in zwei Seiten erschöpfen sich die Texte zu. Und dann schleicht man da so durch so ein Buch durch und kriegt eine Hörerfahrung und Erlebnisse nach der anderen. Weil das sind dann immer irgendwelche YouTube Videos und so weiter, die auch alle noch mit so einer Krautreporter-URL-Abkürzung. Weil da hing er ja auch mal drin. Also da hat er sich irgendwie den URL kürzer genommen und ihn jetzt auf Ewigkeit in das Buch einfach reingeschrieben. Um mal auch die Hohokultur hier zur Geltung zu bringen. Ja, natürlich.
Also wir schleichen uns in die Klassik.
Genau, das ist eigentlich ein Schleichweg.
Machen das jetzt auch mit dem Modigliani-Quartett. Das ist ein Streichquartett, das schon sehr viele berühmte Stücke eingespielt hat und deren neue CD versammelt zwei Streichquartette. Eines von Edward Grieg, den kennen wir durch sein Stück Per Gint, durch die Morgenstimmung. Und ein weiteres Quartett auf dieser CD stammt von Beatrix Smetana, den kennen wir von Mein Vaterland, vor allem das Stück Die Moldau, wird jeder mal gehört haben. Und diese beiden Komponisten sind nicht dafür bekannt, dass sie in erster Linie Streichquartettkomponisten sind. Waren sie auch nicht. Aber sie haben dann jeweils ein Streichquartett oder ich glaube sogar zwei geschrieben. Bei Grieg ist dann eines verloren gegangen. Jedenfalls ist hier von Edward Grieg das erste Streichquartett und von Smetana auch das erste Streichquartett aufgenommen. Und das Besondere ist, diese Komponisten kannten sich nicht. Der eine Norweger, der andere Tscheche. Und diese Komponisten waren jeweils Vertreter einer nationalen Schule, da der Nationalismus des 19. Jahrhunderts ja auch dazu geführt hat, dass man sich absetzen wollte als eigenständige Nation durch die Kultur. Und so ist dann ja auch Mein Vaterland von Smetana zum Beispiel entstanden. Was diese beiden Komponisten aber verbindet ist, dass sie mit herben Schlicksalzschlägen zu tun haben. Und zwar ist da Krieg, der mehrere Verluste zu betreuen hat aus der Familie, der auch beruflich gerade in einer ganz schwierigen Situation sich befindet. Und da ist Beatrix Smetana, der große Erfolge feiern konnte, nun aber taub ist. Nicht nur Beethoven war taub, auch Smetana wurde taub. Und sie setzen sich hin in dieser wirklich existenziellen Krise und komponieren jede für sich ein Quartett, das dann persönlich geprägt ist, das auch von den nationalen Ausprägungen insofern handelt, als dort volkstümliche Musik mit aufgenommen wird. Also eine Polka erklingt zum Beispiel bei Smetana. Und es sind hinreißende Kompositionen, die auch dann wieder sagen, ja, diese ganzen nationalen Schulen, alles Quatsch am Ende. Am Ende zählt dann doch, was der Mensch als solcher empfindet und was er aus seinem empfohenen Leid dann machen kann, wie er es kompensieren kann in große Kunst. Und besonders gefällt mir das Quartett von Smetana. Das ist aufgeteilt in vier Sätze. Es ist keine Programmmusik, aber es erzählt doch von seinem Leben. Denn es heißt auch From My Life, also Aus meinem Leben. Und dort erzählt er von der Jugend. Es beginnt aber schon von Anfang an dramatisch. Man merkt also, hier stimmt schon etwas nicht mehr. Es ist nicht einfach nur freudiger Ausdruck, Leidenschaft. Dann das Alegro Moderato ist eine Polka. Smetana soll ein sehr guter Tänzer gewesen sein. Das Lago dann erinnert an seine geliebte Frau, wie er sie kennenlernte. Und dann beim vierten Satz, dem Vivace, hören wir eine Dramatik, eine große Trauer. Plötzlich, er tönt ein ganz hoher Ton. Und das ist das Zeichen für seine Taubheit. Das ist auch der Tinnitus, den er hatte, den bringt er also da direkt in das Quartett hinein. Aber auch jenseits dieser sehr persönlichen Zugangsweisen, die man dazu finden kann, also um jetzt autobiografisch daran zu gehen, auch jenseits des autobiografischen, hat dieses Stück eine solche Dynamik und Leidenschaft und so eine zugleich wohlgeordnete Kommunikation der Instrumente miteinander. Denn darum geht es ja immer beim Streichquartett, dass die Instrumente miteinander komponieren. Das gibt es natürlich in vielen Einspielungen. Mir hat jetzt diese Neuanspielung vom Kratur Modigliani besonders gut deshalb gefallen, weil sie diese Leidenschaft haben, diese Intensität, aber dann auch gerade in den Pianostellen eine wunderbare Transparenz uns zeigen. Wenn Töne sind ja nicht zu sehen, aber man muss es dann so sagen, wenn Töne durchsichtig werden, wenn es nur so ganz leicht schimmert und sich doch alles trifft, dann hat man große Quartettkunst erlebt und das ist hier der Fall. Also ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, das zu hören. Und das sind jetzt dramatische Geschichten, die ich hier vorgestellt habe von Komponisten in tiefer Verzweiflung. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da nur trübsinnig das hört, sondern man sieht eigentlich aus der Verzweiflung heraus, kann dann große Mitreißende und ich möchte das ganz simpel sagen, schöne Kunst entstehen und noch besser ist, wenn es so hervorragend eingespielt ist.
Ja, sehr gut. Als Christina Stömer, da man ihr Album gemacht hat, zum In der Stadt heißt das, glaube ich, habe ich auch einfach geschrieben, das ist einfach schöne Kunst. Und interessanterweise saß sie im Fernsehen bei dieser Bettina Böttinger, als sie das vorgelesen wurde. Ich habe also gesehen, wie sie erfahren hat, was sich über ihr Musik im FAZ Völtau geschrieben hat, weil sie erst große Augen machte. Im FAZ Völtau bin ich, ah, schöne Kunst, okay. Darf man ruhig mal sagen. Termine. Wir wollen auch Wolfgangs feine Töne hören auf der Bühne.
Soll ich jetzt künftig singen? Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, das bringt nur mich in Zugzwang.
Genau, ich singe erst, wenn Stefan singt.
Siehst du, schon geht es los. Wir sind 2025 in der KS. Am Samstag, dem 15. März, Freitag, dem 20. Juni, Freitag, dem 19. September und Freitag, dem 19. Dezember.
Und immer der letzte Monat eines Quartals, März, Juni, September, Dezember. Und die Karten kosten, wie gehabt, 24 Euro.
Oder 24,80 Euro oder so. Aber so in diesem Dreh. Ihr erfahrt das bei Mustafar, dem ihr eine E-Mail schreibt, wie die letzten Jahre auch. Neuezwanziger at dcass.de. Keine Umlaute, keine Zahlen, sondern einfach nur ausgeschrieben. Neuezwanziger at dcass.de. Also dcass mit ae.
Mit ae. Also d-i-e-k-a-e-s.
Und rückwärts. Genau so. Ich schreibe die Daten auch in den Text und auch in die Kapitelmarke, denn im Salon weiß ich, dass ich den Text in die Paywall bringen kann, ohne dass sofort alle sehen, wann die Salonisten das wegkaufen können. Bei Apple, glaube ich, geht das nicht, aber in der Kapitelmarke jetzt, in einfachen Klammern, alle vier Termine drin. März, 20. Juni, 19. September, 19.
Dezember. Wir freuen uns schon auf die Live-Termine und freuen uns auf euch alle. Und wir werden dann, ja, gespannt diesen Monat verfolgen. Wer weiß, was noch alles kommt.
Oh, das wird aufregend.
Erst einmal eine gute Zeit.
Bis dahin.